good morning everyone
if i just ask everyone just to turn
their cameras off please
and to go on mute and we'll before we
make a start
thank you um good morning everyone and
can i welcome you please
to the planning referrals committee of
mid-suffolk district council
um my name is matthew hicks and i'm
chairing this meeting
and myself my fellow councillors will
today make a decision on the application
before us
so i want to move on to agenda item
number one
apologies for absence do we have any
apologies for absence please
jeff i may do a roll call yep comments
members if you could uh reply
when i call your name councillor james
caston present
matthew hicks president uh councillor
barry humphries we have apologies
councillor sarah mancell we have
apologies
councillor john matheson president
councillor andrew mellon present
councillor richard mayer president
councillor david muller present
councillor mike norris
president councillor andrew stringer
president
councillor roland warboys present and we
also have councillor harry richardson
as a ward member uh present thank you
uh you forgot me claire council
augustine i do apologize councillor
guthrie
i'm here thank you
thank you very much okay next item
on the agenda is to receive any
decorations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
members if you have any procunary or
non-procurement interests can i ask you
to just raise your hand
on the hand function please
okay that's none received so i take it
there are no further declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members thank you
next item is declarations of lobbying to
members
i have been lobbied is there anyone
i think we've probably all received the
same emails
hands up if you have been lobbied please
uh and i'm looking down the list
and i think that's pretty much
that's you can see the list there so
just to be clear it's councillor mayor
muller gold casting guthrie matheson
e burn melon field norris stringer and
hattingham
thank you very much if you could take
your hands down
and guthrie thank you
is there anyone i haven't read out that
would like to come in that i've missed
no thank you okay um
next item is declarations of personal
site visits have there been any personal
site visits by members again if you have
done that please raise your hand so we
can see
okay so we have
we have one hand up councillor mellon
and councillor matheson okay
thank you they've been registered
um we now need to look at the
confirmation of the minutes and the
meeting held on the 12th of august 2020.
now have they followed
on claire could you talk us through that
uh no chair draft of the minutes has
been prepared and they are currently
awaiting sign off
okay so they'll come to the next meeting
excuse me matthew sorry for button
buttoning you didn't register me for
lobbying
oh thank you sorry roland thank you for
your coming back on that
okay so those minutes of the meeting
held on the 12th of august we'll come to
the next meeting
thank you very much agenda item number
six is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme do we have any please
non-received chair
okay well we have one planning
application before us today
it's the land to the east of ixworth
road thurston dc
1902090
and to presenting today is vincent so
vincent over to you thank you
thank you chad can i just check that i
am displaying
my screen and you can see the
presentation yes we can excellent thank
you
so good morning everyone um ladies and
gentlemen who may be
listening and watching as the chair says
we're looking at this application
for it's an outline application 210
dwellings
in thurston and
i'm just gonna have to read but there we
go right now first i'm afraid i have to
give you a short explanation for people
who are listening
you may hear reference to page numbers
that don't accord with the ones that you
have
got if you've used the online version of
the agenda
and that's because the version that was
sent to
our counselors had a slightly different
numbering system
the documents in themselves are exactly
the same they contain exactly the same
information
but as you can see from this mock-up
some start from page seven
whereas others are labeled 1a to 13
a now this might seem a little bit
confusing but in essence
all you need to know is they are the
same documents and behind the scenes
we will manage reference to page numbers
so that everyone knows exactly
where we are on whichever agenda
you are using so apologies for that but
in these trying circumstances we we sent
one version out
ahead of the other and there had been a
little adjustment to the page numbering
so hopefully you can bear with us and
apologies for any
problems that may cause
so the key parts of i need just to
explain the structure of the report
because this
application has been on three agendas
since
january so the current agenda for the
16th
of september has an addendum
which appears on page 7 to 19
if you're using the web agenda or 1a to
13 a
if you're using the paper agenda and
this simply updates the report
that appeared on the 12th of august and
members will recall we didn't get the
chance to debate
this item at that meeting and since that
meeting
there's been some updates so what i've
done is just bring you up to speed with
what's happened
in the intervening month and then the
rest of the agenda picks up the previous
report of the 12th of august
and also includes the one from the 29th
of january
i have explained that process here
so what we're going to do is because we
haven't considered this application
since it was deferred in january
i have to remind members of all the
relevant issues that are
are germane and we we need to go through
traffic implications
questions around connectivity of this
site and the rest of the village
landscape impacts questions of
infrastructure sustainability we also
need to look at the
status of the current planning policy
and its
relationship to the made and adopted
thurston neighborhood development plan
we need to think about our five-year
housing land supply residential amenity
and at the end we're going to have to do
the balance the planning balance where
we're looking at benefits
and impacts but
first i need to just give the usual
um caveat that this presentation merely
supports
and complements the comprehensive report
you have
before you so this will pick out
uh issues that i want to highlight in
terms of diagrams
but the report is the thing that we will
all refer to as we go through
now members who are present on the 29th
of january
will remember that this item was
deferred and at the time
and i've got the minute on the screen
members resolved
that the application that they were
minded to refuse
but they wanted the following points
examined in more detail
so as officers we were required to go
away and do further
analysis of the highway situation
particularly the bumbry arms
and in terms of the barton road station
hill
junction and access to the station
we were required to go away and report
on
updates on station improvements
members wanted greater certainty over
landscape buffer around the
and then members wanted us to come back
with that information
so as officers during the intervening
nine months we've looked again at the
capacity of the bumbry arms
junction with our colleagues at suffolk
county council
and their consultants acom so i can
report on the findings from that
we've looked at the extent to which
mover technology and if you remember
this is the
the added um
106 offer from gladman's that actually
allows the traffic lights to be
operated in real time they have sensors
in the road that
that understand where cues are forming
and they can change the lights to
respond accordingly
we've gone away and achieved some
enhancements in terms of connectivity
particularly to meadow lane but also the
rest of the village with glebman since
that meeting
we've also managed to secure enhanced
crossings
around the village much improved
landscaping
i can update you on station improvements
and there is now an expanded 106.
so our starting point and this was a
point that was as raised
by councillor richardson when we met in
january and attracted some support from
a number of members on the committee
around what is the status of the
planning policies and where does the
thirsted neighborhood plan fit into that
spectrum well the first thing we must
acknowledge is that thurston
is a key service center and members will
know
that what that actually means is
thurston as a
key service center is a focus for
development
second only in our settlement hierarchy
two towns
so the basic presumption is that as a
sustainable
location thurston will receive
additional development so in terms of
your
local plan the star represents the
application
site it is outside of the defined
settlement boundary for thurston
in terms of the neighborhood plan again
the star
is the application site everything in
grey is
what we might call the set model it is
the settlement boundary for thurston
as agreed in the thurston neighborhood
plan and you'll notice that the site
is outside of the settlement boundary
this is where the issue becomes a little
more complicated because in your joint
local plan which we acknowledge at the
moment carries limited weight
the site that appears in it as la 089
is the application site
it is the council's intention going
forward at this stage
to allocate that site for residential
development
and within the jlp
it suggests that it's capable of
accommodating approximately 200
dwellings
and then there's the list of caveats
that you see on that
that list so an application at 210
dwellings is within the scope of
approximately
200 dwellings
now within the jlp the council has
identified
a housing requirement in thurston for
1468
dwellings now this
conflicts with the thirst
neighborhood plan which identifies
sites capable of accommodating
818 dwellings on sites that already have
the benefit of
planning permission if we factor in
the blah home site at bayton road that
was the application you resolved to
grant
in january that was 210 dwellings if you
add in the
admin site where you grant planning
permission today that's another 210
that will bring the total to pro in the
region of 1238
so you'll notice that there is a
shortfall compared to the
neighborhood plan and the jlp now i
think
certainly when we hear from the parish
council they will be saying
that as the adopted neighborhood plan
we should be adhering to the numbers
within the
neighborhood plan and that's the point
we will come and debate
as we go through the presentation
now members will recall and i think this
is something that um
councillor warboyz was particularly
strong
on there was concern that
members couldn't fully consider the the
merits of this particular application
when there was a lot of uncertainty
about the fishwick corner
improvements now you remember fishwick
corner to the south of
thurston was also the subject of a
planning application in
west suffolk district
so on the screen you'll note all the
housing on that plan
is in mid-suffolk and in january you
resolved ground planning permission
subject to a section 106 agreement
but the my cursor's working this area in
here which created a new access
in here away from this crossroads to
create a new staggered junction
that piece was in west suffolk and
understandably
people like councillor walboy said
should we be allowing more development
when this very important highway work
may never happen if west suffolk
district council wants to refuse that
application
because with the dayton road application
there is a significant package of
highway works
very important highway works most of
these are identified in the neighborhood
plan
as being necessary before additional
development could even be contemplated
in
thurston but what happened is when
west suffolk district council considered
the highway
junction improvements they deferred it
and were minded to refuse
but when it went back to them bloor
had agreed to provide this extended
cycleway
all the way from effectively from berry
right up to the station
at that point so in
on the third of june west suffolk
district
agreed or resolved grant planning
permission for those works
so what i can now report is that both
councils are working on the 106
and are looking to issue the planning
decisions
as soon as those 106s have been signed
so i can give you more comfort this time
councillor warboys that
that shouldn't be an issue going forward
we've obviously got the issue of phasing
around when those works happen
but i will come on to that as we as we
go through
so just to remind you this is the scheme
in red that you saw we'll just go back
quickly i can press one button
in red is the lebron proposal that you
looked at in january
you'll notice that in the darker brown
biscuit color
we have two sites adjacent that are
already under construction
linden homes and persimmon homes the
pink
colored area called lawrence homes we
understand they also have permission
they are about to
to start so the point i made in january
is that this site is
in large part in fill between existing
uh developments that are underway so
what's different
well we know that first and pal parish
council object
they maintain that objection i'm sure
we'll hear from them this morning
but the point that certainly came up
last time and this is something that
council
eben was very strong in emphasizing and
had support from other members was
how confident are we that this site can
be adequately buffered
because parts of it are on the edge of
the countryside
so on the left you have the january
version on the right you have the
september version and you'll notice
straight away
that what we have is a new system of
green links that
crisscross the site north south east
west
but the first point i want to draw out
is i want to look at this boundary
because i know rachel
councillor eben you were very strong in
wanting to ensure that the boundary on
the east with meadow lane was
at least 20 meters wide
so what we've done is we've gone away
and i can confirm
that they will be 20 meters wide
it will be extended the existing
hedgerow will be extended
we will cover that in terms of a
condition
in terms of the proposed access this is
off of ix-worth road
so on this screen the red circle with
the red arrow
is the proposed access and the access
the blue arrow
in the blue circle is the emergency
vehicle
access now what i need to draw to your
attention
is the visibility display now remember
that this is now turned on its side
north is
on this diagram is on the on the left
and there is
a 215 meter visibility splayer and
that's important when we come to
consider the buffers
the landscape buffers what we're also
getting at that
new access is a three meter way wide
footweight cycleway that will connect to
the footwear
cycleway that is being provided by
simmon
on the other side of the road so
immediately we have started to
secure excellent connectivity to the
footway cycleway network in thurston
we now need to look again at other bits
of the buffer and here i want to just
drive you
from the north to the south towards
thurston
along x with road and on the left you'll
see some arrows that
mark where we are on that that journey
members will be familiar with some
recent issues we've had in
thurston over the loss of trees
associated with the
persimmon development this video i think
will be
is speeded up so it's not necessarily me
moving at high speed it's simply
reducing the length of the
the video so we have wooded areas
left and right
now you'll notice on the left we've got
the blue arrow so
we're now moving everything on the left
is the gladman sight and you'll notice
the new development on the right
that is the persimmon development so
we've got the field on the left that's
gladman a short
section of scrubby hedge open frontage
to gladman's site
another bit of scrubby hedge with a
with a tree and then we're coming to the
edge of
thurston again still persimmon on the
right
we're gradually coming up to the
complicated junction at ixworth road
norton road station hill we've got the
community college on the right
just starting to appear
we're now deeper into thurston
we're coming up to the junction we've
got the college
on the right and we're just going to
turn right into
norton road where the school is
and the college is an important hub
within the village and that should stop
there so
originally in january the onyx with road
with the visibility display the black
dotted line
is the visibility display and what
you'll notice is the planting was shown
in front of the visibility display in
here now what that means is
any planting there couldn't be higher
than 600
millimeters understandably members were
concerned that that
would mean the development behind would
be exposed
and what we wanted to do was try and
restore
that natural country lane hedgerow
feel that's been lost on both sides of
the road at that point
so in discussion with gladman's what we
have done is we have now secured
a 20 meter deep buffer so that's the
same as on the eastern side
behind that vision display so as you
travel down exworth road in the future
where you might need to grow planning
permission and it was implemented
you would actually have a deep
planting belt that would restore some of
the natural character
of ixworth road so here we have that
display we're looking back from the
north towards thurston
the yellow is the vision display and
what we'll effectively have
is a hedgerow running all the way down
there
i want to point out that since we met in
january
persimmon has almost finished delivering
the
new footway cycleway on the western side
of ixworth road and that's important in
terms of
connectivity so i'll just quickly
take you along exworth road and you can
see on the left
that new footway cycleway
the gladman site will connect to that
via a crossing and we'll notice on the
right how open the gladman site is at
the moment
very exposed there is a lot of
development on the
left on its way
so we've reached the edge of the admin
site
in terms of existing hedgerow as i
described and as you saw as we went
through
the video the bits in red are areas of
existing flora that we will be likely to
lose
but as you can see let's go back
there isn't much there in in the first
place so what we can
say is the whole of that length except
for where the road goes in
will now be a 20 meter deep landscape
buffer
what we're looking to do is create a
natural hedgerow containing
typical indigenous rural species
so not only will it provide a glorious
visual treat but it also provides
wonderful habitat
and will increase biodiversity
again counselor eben and others were
very strong on
let's create some green corridors so
if we look at this little picture on the
top right this is a
slice north south through the site where
we have one of the new green links
so we have this landscaped corridor we
can almost call it a as a green link it
is an ecological
corridor it's a network that allows
wildlife to move between existing areas
of wildlife
but for pedestrians we've also got these
raised tables which make it
pedestrian friendly and the same
is true on the west east link
that we've secured through the site so
here you can see the green link and
we've got the
pedestrian raised tables as well to
improve access
as well as that members were keen that
we should encourage
pedestrian cycle activity in meadow lane
and we will have that connection now
and that would be an important corridor
for people trying to get to the new
primary school which is also
just to the east of meadow lane so again
we're beginning to
reinforce the pedestrian and cycle
network in
thurston we also need to look at
recreation
we have secured agreement to a financial
contribution of 200 pounds 200 pounds
200
000 pounds which will go
towards maintenance and
equipment within the large area of open
space
that is being gifted where you'd grant
permission
for a pound at the northern end of the
site on this slide you'll see the area
there's this large swathe of open space
to the north that runs around
down the east and along the the southern
boundaries
part of that will be used to provide
a car free fitness well-being
perimeter track and the only point where
vehicles
would come into contact potentially with
pedestrians would be at the access but
if we were clever
we'd build some loops into that network
so you could start at this end you could
jog walk take your dog all the way
around
do a loop and come back and that would
be entirely
color free on the right i've listed some
of the
thoughts that we've had about what
should be included we're suggesting that
the gym trail
for example be conditioned
we're talking potentially there could be
a community orchard that's the bit that
we would like to
explore with local people
skateboarding figures heavily in the
thurston neighborhood plan
there are many references to it and it's
one of the policy five in the neighbor
plan points to this sort of recreational
facility
at the moment the parish council so here
we have the
admin site here we have the community
college
at the moment this area of of greenland
is as it isn't developed now
suffolk county council are currently
proposing a muga
multi-use games area with the yellow
dotties
there is discussion with thurston parish
council about them having a recreation
area where the red dot is
then potentially the black dot would be
additional residential
development my understanding is that
potentially a skate park in this area
could be problematic
in terms of the proximity
of these dwellings the latest advice in
terms of proximity of skate parks to
dwellings there should be at least a 40
meter separation
what we're thinking is if the parish
council weren't able to secure the skate
park on their preferred site which is
as i showed previously this site would
actually offer the scope to do that
so where the yellow dots are on this
screen
we could actually create or first and
create a
the latest thinking in skatepark design
are things called skate dots so rather
than have one big center where you have
every facility you spread it out in a
linear form
that creates a more exciting
venue for people to do their skating
so the advantage here is that we have
much deeper
we have 81 meters depth at that corner
down to 72
so you can see how with this sort of
arrangement
through here we could easily achieve
40 meters separation but also that would
fit in with the jogging it would fit in
with everything else
but if uh thurston were to proceed with
the skatepark on the other side
this particular site could be used for
all sorts of recreational
activity so on the left you have the
more traditional form of skatepark
and on the right you have the the new
thinking in terms of skatepark design
with the skate dots
connectivity and again council rebound
was very strong in this and so was
councillor hicks
and this
slide shows on the left we have the
proposed suffolk county council muga
or mugger however you wish to raise it
here we have
the gladman site so in close up
there's the mugger there's the corner of
the gladman site just go back
so on the right here we have the
footwear cycle where that's being
provided by
persimmon there's also an option let's
go around here
to avoid this this tree that new link
will take us
right around that corner to where the
thurston library sits in terms of
norton road this is the linden homes
development we will have all sorts of
connections
green connections through here so that
you can come from the gladman site in
this corner down meadow lane
walk through and get to the new primary
school
that is the new primary school
in terms of access to the station here
we have
an admin site which is very sorry
sensitive to the this is a new crossing
that would be provided by
gladman another new crossing at the
ixworth norton
station hill junction another new
crossing
provided by gladman at heath road
these two crossings are coming via the
thurston five developments
this is the link that persimmon is
providing
we've got existing crossings at these
points and bloor will be doing
improvements to this roundabout so
you're beginning to see
how this development would fit into a
comprehensive network
that is increasingly pedestrian and
cycle
friendly and that would get you to the
station
what about wider connections well
obviously one of the key hubs in the
village in terms of pedestrian activity
is the community
college that actually sits
on national cycle network 51
so obviously we are looking to enhance
cycle
access to the college
so on this plan what we have started to
show the
blue flashing dots are the crossings to
be provided by
the admins we've already secured
speed limit extensions northwards so
that vehicle speeds from
each of these points will be reduced
from these are now in place
these were much closer to the the
village
we've got new footweight cycleways in
these locations this is coming from the
hopkins development
first and five money i'm sorry apologies
this
is let's go back is has already provided
money for
footwear improvements footpath
improvements
so in terms of east west movements
through the village
through here you can see crossing
crossing
crossing crossing crossing
news primary school community college
there is increasingly a safer network
for
pedestrians and cyclists
so let's look at the ixworth road
crossing that will be provided by
gladman's
the yellow and red dotted line is
persimmons footwear cycleway
and this would be a connection from
gladman's to link directly
into that that would be a toucan
crossing so it would be available
for pedestrians and cyclists
in terms of the ixworth norton
station hill junction there you have the
library site
this is ix-worth road disappearing into
the distance
the persimmon footway cycleway comes
around that
corner in that sort of fashion
here's a shot of the new footway cycle
way
being provided by persimmon on icsworth
road
another shot that's the bit where the
path goes around the back of the
the tree we're just quickly going to
take a bit of videos just so you can see
how
this complicated this crossroads
works because it is one of the key
fits the network that currently has very
little
traffic management and we do need to
resolve that
so here we are
we swing around that little gap over the
right is uh and it's there we are
national cycleway 51. if we swing back
at that point there that gap is where
lots of uh pupils come and go
into to get to the school from the
estate beyond
there is no crossing there at the moment
and there is quite a bit of pedestrian
footfall
at the start of the school day and at
the end of the school day
and why that is significant is if we
look at this next slide
i do slow it down as we go so this is
immediately outside the community
college
and where you can see the single pupil
that's where that crossing is into the
estate
and what happens is you can see because
there is no
there are no pedestrian facilities to
get across that road
it can be quite perilous to cross no
criticism of squirrels there but that
that video actually contained something
like
five minutes of just bumper-to-bumper
buses
leaving the school and the reverse
happens in the morning
so at the moment what you've got is the
white dots of the
pedestrian links but there is no
safe way of crossing in terms of traffic
management
measures so what we're looking at
for that is the admins have offered two
zebra crossings
which is a start so you've got the
college over here
there's that little footpath connection
through to the estate in here
so what we would have at the moment is
proposed zebra crossing
zebra crossing so you can see
immediately how that would make it safer
for pupils to get through there
particularly when there's a lot of
traffic
to in and throwing on that junction
however
there are the two separates but what
we're looking at is could we make that
even safer
and suffer county council is now looking
to
introduce for the first time in suffolk
tiger crossings i don't think i've had
the
been able to describe a tiger crossing
to you before
so what is a tiger crossing this is
an illustrative drawing of a tiger
crossing so it actually creates
two separate crossing points
for cycle and pedestrian traffic
so what we're looking at is that
complicated junction
actually now having the tiger crossings
you can start to see how that
so you've got cycle ways footway
in terms of safer routes to school and
encouraging
uh kids to to use their bikes this must
be a safer way to get through that
junction and remember this sits on
national cycleway 51. so what we're
actually doing is reinforcing the
benefits
of cycle travel and again something that
counselor
sarah mansell pointed out last time on
on heath road
here you have what is part of national
cycle route 51 going through these
little railings so this
how safe would that be and where will
the crossing be
so let's just take a little short trip
through video again i've speeded it up
just to
so you come across heath road over the
through that little chicane
that is incredibly quiet there's just a
few houses served up here this is the
old norton road that's effectively been
truncated now by that closure that we've
just come through
so we can walk and cycle through here
quite easily
and safely as soon as we pop through
that little bit of opening
just swing around the back of that van
and here we are delivered to one of the
entrances to the community college
you'll notice in the distance another
crossing point
so here we're looking at toucans
again useful and safer for
cyclists as well and again it fits into
the
so here is national soccer route 51
here's heath road what we don't
necessarily want people to do is go
straight across but we've got this
close enough to make that an attractive
route so what about first and station
now this is something that counselor
field was very strong
on if we are uh suggesting new
development
more new development in thurston
how are we going to get people safely to
the station when we know that there are
certain issues at the station
so let's just rehearse what they are
first issue
is that there isn't a direct link
between the platforms and on this side
there isn't a direct link to this
platform
from the street which is significantly
at the bottom of this embankment so at
the moment
there's a and thing known as a sac
barrow crossing
in here so what happens is here we are
we want to get across
so what we actually do we will cross
over there and then we're back up here
now obviously that means you are
crossing railway tracks
that are in active use so at the moment
there are safety measures there are
cameras
there's warning collections
and there are a red or a green light
system
for pedestrians to cross
the next issue is the narrowness of the
footwear
under the bridge so here we have it's
wide enough for one person so you can
walk through there
as part of the bayton road development
we've secured improvements to widen that
path under the bridge
so effectively you now can have two
people
pass together
the other issue that's been pointed out
is thurston has a very small
car park now in some ways if we were to
increase the size of that
car park we might actually be
encouraging people to
travel from the edge of barry to catch
us
a train from from here but it certainly
is an issue that's been raised
locally what we would want to do is
encourage people to walk to the station
or cycle to
station from within thurston
now you may recall last time i said that
parties were working together to try and
come up with solutions to those problems
and i can report that uh about 10 days
ago
mid suffolk's cabinet agreed to release
100 000 pounds
to fund the feasibility study to deliver
a
solution to gaining safer access
to the platforms that would mean that we
could
close the barrow crossing now the idea
is that soon as that
feasibility study has been completed and
the preferred option is identified
more money would be released potentially
millions of pounds to
enhance safety at the station through
sil and members will recall that
thurston
has taken a lot of development is taking
a lot of
development and that is generating
significant sill
funds they will be reinvested in
thurston to deliver solutions to
the station and other things
bunbury arms this was perhaps the
biggest issue on the day
in back in january and certainly
councillor field and council of mensah
were very
strong in demanding that officers
demonstrate that there would be capacity
at bunbury arms to take this
additional development i think it's fair
to say there was a little bit of
skepticism
as to whether we could actually
demonstrate that
so what happened is after that meeting
additional traffic survey work was
undertaken
that survey work was undertaken before
the covid
crisis hit so the figures were not
reduced because people weren't traveling
so
those figures were then used and fed
into the acom model
and you'll recall that acom are
independent
traffic consultants working for suffolk
county council
and up came the modeling work and we'll
look at that
but also i think members may have
thought
how come that
without significant changes to these
proposed signalization
how can capacity be created well the
answer is twofold first of all the mover
technology
actually provides additional capacity
because it it effectively more
effectively controls
traffic flow through that junction at
bunbury arms
but also nationally there has been
for the last five years a reduction in
trips across the country so
car usage is going down well obvious and
we'll exclude the current covid
situation because obviously
that's meant there's been a plummeting
of trips
but the trend is a reduction in
trips so that even that has added
capacity to that junction
so if we look at the national figures
and these are figures
that we haven't made them up and it's
not something that suffolk
county councillors has has produced
itself these are the national figures
these are the latest figures
from the government in terms of annual
trips
and you'll notice how those trips
petrol cars have been going down diesel
cars have been going down dramatically
all the all these other trips have been
going down
that's important when we're looking at
modeling because for some
because obviously we're also predicting
travel movements
into the future so the trend is
definitely now
which a reduction in car trips which is
a good thing
but that feeds into the modeling as well
as all the other factors
so if we look at some of these movements
now this is quite
complicated but i'll just draw out the
the significant pieces of this but what
you'll notice
understandably is the majority of
traffic
is east-west along the a143 so
in the morning
we are predicting some 478
traffic movements within that hour
traveling east
937 traffic movements
traveling west at the same time
we've got 234 people
attempting to get out of thurston
during that peak hour
in the afternoon we get a
understandably we get a reverse we've
got nearly a thou
over a thousand vehicles coming back to
thurston
in the afternoon much fewer traveling
towards
westwards and fewer trying to get out of
thurston so everyone's trying to get
back to thurston
and there is a that actually describes
all the movements on that junction but
the important point to note is that
in the morning you have 199
vehicles trying to get into thurston
whether that's from the west the north
or the east
understandably you've got more people
trying to get out
in all directions in the afternoon
understandably that has reversed more
people trying to get back into thurston
then they're trying to to leave it and
that's important
when you look at a situation where
currently there are no signals so that's
the junction at the moment
here's the bunbury arms here's the road
into thurston
this is the a143 so we quickly fly
around that
that junction
strangely no traffic at that point
but that is the
the junction
and we'll just let that come to a stop
so here we have a situation in the
morning just to try and
explain those models so we have a lot of
traffic as you recall going east
a lot of traffic going west and here we
are trying to get out of first and
someone to go left someone to go right
but because
without signals it's so difficult to get
across
this q builds up and up
so it's increasingly frustrating if you
are trying to get out of
first and in the morning in the
afternoon you've got a lot of traffic
still on the a143
but as soon as somebody stops to turn
right to get into thirst and because
this significant traffic coming this way
you start to get tailbacks and then
traffic wanting to go straight on
has to start sitting behind the traffic
that's waiting to go right
so you start getting cues building up on
the a 143
clearly undesirable but that's the
current situation
so in terms of q
lengths i'm not going to explain with
signals
you start these are the q lengths with
signals
you think well hang on a minute why is
why we got these long
queues here compared to these without
signals
but actually if we add the queue
in the morning the red is the queue
trying to get out of
thurston that queue can be 46 cars long
with signalization you end up with only
11 in that queue
that's the impact that signalization has
for people in thurston significant
benefit
in the afternoon
actually you managed to secure is
potentially that is the length of the
queue for people trying to get
back into thurston
signalization reduces that q
dramatically and what it is doing is
it's
making more efficient decisions around
movements
we now have that we didn't have in
january the junction design and i
i can remember councillor field you said
something along the lines of
how on earth you're going to create
additional space
at that junction and actually
additional space can be created road
space
so let's zoom into that junction
the dots black dots are signals new
traffic signals
and i've started doing green show that
how the lanes would work in the
approaches so you can see approaching
from the
west you can have a right turn filter
you've made it clearer for traffic users
to
get around that junction by mark
demarcating the the turning
maneuvering lanes then what happens is
so here is the engrave the existing
road space now the first thing that's
going to happen here is
you see that corner is widened
to allow people to slip off left far
more easily
that is an efficient way of easing
capacity at that junction
we also then on this corner can do the
same thing
and then on this corner some extra
flaring can occur
and then here there's a build out where
the existing hatch
crosshatch markings are
that already increases capacity so the
alterations to the junction and the
signals
produce increased capacity
and as we've explained the suffolk
county council are working with aecom
and that's a quote from their website
just to demonstrate that a comma
are world renowned engineers
and they are independent so suffolk have
gone out
to get that advice to be sure that their
own calculation and thinking is
is robust and the advice is that yes it
is robust acom of
i've looked at all of that but i do need
to take a little bit of time to run
through the
county council's formal consultation
response
and i'll do it so i'll take the first
sentence and the county council have
said as the highway authority we have
examined this application
and the supporting information in detail
the additional development
will lead to more vehicles pedestrians
and cyclists using the highway network
around thurston
in addition to that from the permitted
developments
next point is they then say without
mitigation
we consider that the cumulative impacts
are severe
in highway terms so let's look at that
without mitigation impacts would be
severe
in this proposal we are looking at
mitigation
and i explain why that's important in
the next sentence
however with the proposed mitigation
we consider that while some significant
negative factors remain
the overall impact when balanced the
impact is no longer severe
nor is there unacceptable impact on road
safety
now members may want to understand with
what do they mean by either county
council when they say
significant negative factors remain
well the answer to that is there will be
an estimated 126
vehicles additional vehicles within and
around the village during the am peak
so what we don't want to do is disguise
the fact that there will be
added vehicular activity
but what we need to highlight is the
fact that there will be
additional mitigation for pedestrians
and and cyclists
and on that basis
the county council concludes for these
reasons we advise that we do not
recommend that this application is
refused
we also need to look at paragraph 109 of
the mppf
which deals with the question of
highway impacts specifically
and i will read it because it's
important we drill down into this
109 says development should only
be prevented or refused on highway
grounds
if there would be an unacceptable impact
on highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
would be severe so if we look at that
first bit
unacceptable impact on highway safety
the county council has said nor is there
an unacceptable impact on road safety
in terms of the second test cumulative
impacts on the road network
would be severe the county council has
specifically said
impact is no longer severe
and this demonstrates
how bunbury arms
capacity has been improved so
here is the junction without mitigation
and there are
two parts of that junction that are over
capacity without mitigation
so we've got the a143 on the west side
and
thurston road in thurston road in the
morning the a143
west in the afternoon and i demonstrated
that issue of
getting out in the morning and coming
home to thurston
in the afternoon but with traffic
signals
capacity has been increased
so that we no longer are in the over
capacity
situation and virtually in every example
here
we're well within the theoretical
capacity so that is a significant
increase in capacity
with all development loaded onto that
junction
and with the glebman proposal and what
this
doesn't include is the impact of mover
the real-time traffic management
software
so we need to look at mover to see what
it it does
and what mover does is actually adjusts
the green time or the red time
of traffic lights at the junction by
second by second understanding how much
traffic is using
each arm of the junction
and when it detects cues forming it
changes the
sequencing of the lights to create the
most efficient
traffic management system
generally three ways to
deploy mover county council prefer the
induction loops in the road and they are
set into the road surface
and they work on magnetic force they
detect the metal of the cars
lorries and vans moving over the top you
can have
microwave detectors on top of the
signals to detect vehicles in a queue
or you can actually have them button
controlled
as well normally
traffic lights are pre-programmed so
seven days a week 24 hours a day
365 days of the year somebody has sat
down a programmer and worked
out what the signal sequence should be
so here we've got for example
short burst of green longer burst of red
short burst of green longer and that is
just programmed it's fixed
so no matter what the traffic is doing
on the day if it's not
following the usual pattern the lights
are stuck with the pre-programmed
sequencing however what mover does is
the blue uh elements are the detectors
in the road and they're constantly
monitoring traffic so in this example
the induction loop is saying hang on a
minute we're detecting a little bit of
additional traffic on this arm if we're
going to avoid a cue what we need to do
is have a longer phase of green
before we go to red it does some more
detecting
and it's no that hasn't done it yet
we've still got this
q forming let's give another short red
and a longer burst of green
and then it detects that traffic is back
to flowing efficiently
and it goes to the and it's doing that
24 hours a day
changing signals depending on how
traffic
is using the arms of the the junction
and that can
increase capacity by up to 13
on average thirteen percent but there
are some examples where people have
achieved much higher
uh improvements so already i've
demonstrated that with signals
that junction has adequate capacity
the mover element adds another
amount of additional capacity so i think
at the previous meeting in journey i
think councilor menzel was referring to
the junction
being over capacity i think we can
safely say
that at no point during that day will
that junction be over capacity
with signalization and mover and that's
important to understand because
i've demonstrated the benefits for the
people of thurston in terms of getting
out of that junction
to go to work or school or if you're
leaving in the morning and when you come
back in the evening
afternoon you have a much easier journey
because you're not sitting in a long
queue
at that junction we need to think about
residential amenity because obviously
there's a lot of building activity going
on in thurston
we have had some issues in meadow lane
and you'll recall that this
site has access to to meadow lane in so
far as linden homes have been using
meadow lane temporarily
to provide construction access to their
site
but the new purpose-built
junctions on norton road are either
nearing completion or have been
completed
so they will stop using meadow lane
we're confident that were you to grant
plenty permission for this glenman
development
we would be able to ensure that the
developer did not use meadow lane
as their construction access so the
residents in meadow lane
should going forward have a much less
disturbed
daily routine from construction traffic
but it's true there's a lot of
construction traffic
in thurston this would add to it if you
granted plenty permission
but the county council is now operating
a coordinated management system
between all the developers and i'm sure
my colleagues can explain how that is
being
operated to try and minimize disruption
within thurston now something that came
up and it's not necessarily a material
consideration but i do want to go
through it it's something that um
counselor matheson brought up and he
argued very strongly
i think council you were very concerned
that additional development
in thurston would put pressure on
gp services in woolpit will pit being
the
natural um destination
for patients from thurston there isn't a
gp in
thurston so i have to quickly put
the catchment areas and as you can see
people in thurston are expected to go to
the gpm
wool pit that isn't
in itself uncommon
in rural suffolk so you can see for
example
debenham people uh in deb and america
the catchment for the enemies is equally
as
as large and that's probably true of
most rural settlements in
suffolk however in terms
of access that's an eight kilometer
distance from thurston to the woolpet
surgery
but what we have secured and i'm sure
councillor geek or
councillor mansour if they were i think
the council mentions not here
unfortunately
would confirm that we're working very
closely with them in wool pit
because we have secured additional land
through development to expand health
care facilities in wool pit
so councillor mattis and when you were
saying how could the ball pit surgery
cope
the answer is we've we've secured a site
that's
probably as big slightly bigger than the
existing site that would allow
expansion so working with
sill money and the ccg we can ensure
that
health facilities for the people of
thurston can keep up with demand
sustainability well this site here
is incredibly close to the college
and incredibly close to the new primary
school you couldn't get much closer so
in terms of sustainability
pupils will be easily and safely able to
walk to
either the community college or the
primary school
in terms of the distance to the station
here we are in the middle of
the gladman site
it's uh three-fifths of a mile book
that can all be achieved on footways
with the new crossings that is
a very convenient and easy walk
to and from the station from this site
here we have cycle route number 51
the national route and as you can see
it goes right through thurston
and that's important because thurston is
very
cycle conscious before the covid
situation they were organizing
all kinds of activities here we had one
promoting
join the thurston cycle loop there are
bike
main or there were bike maintenance
saturday so thurston is very switched on
to encouraging
cycling activity so let's take a quick
cycle along 51 route 51 here we are
just opposite the community college
we're going to move at
five times the speed that it was taken
in
we're moving southwards along the
cycle route
you'll notice across the existing
crossing
those cars aren't moving and that's
that's b remember that i've speeded the
video up
to the left we have the the community
center way down that for there and new
green a large open space in the heart of
thurston we come through
there we are there's somebody using
their scooter we're on the footway cycle
way we're going right through
no cars this is entirely car free except
we just have to cross this little
there's the community center a bit of
residential and over we go
and that takes us right the way through
to thread wester
if we there so on the right we've got
the
playground we're still car free we're
going through there
community facilities on the left and
then we end up
in said westeros
road again
incredibly well used in
nice safe cycle pedestrian network
and we're back out onto the and that's
just shows where we've just cut through
past the community cafe
linking threadrest systrestra to station
hill
in terms of the northern road as part of
the london homes development we've got
more
cycleway footways so if you're cycling
to school
you can get to the primary school safely
buses a large number of bus stops in the
village
i think some rural communities would be
envious of the
surf bus services that service the
village
we've got a railway station that
provides access to
london and cambridge peterborough
norwich
a good timetable of trains this is the
kovid timetable
facilities in thurston are
numerous in terms of biodiversity we're
securing packages that
by condition that and we're suggesting a
section 106 that would include
integrated bird nesting boxes into some
of the houses
hedgehog friendly fencing even bat boxes
built into some of the houses
on on the walls we're getting new
hedgerow
habitats wetland areas
through the suds we're going for
innovative solutions to
suds on this site where you to grant
permission
new grassland meadow land within the
open space
in terms of the section 106 we are
getting education contributions
totaling 1.45 million
pounds important as the population
increases we have to make sure that the
local education
centers can cope so you're already
getting a new primary school
in thurston paid for by development
we're getting a large area of open space
for a pound that has a value somewhere
in the region of
350 000 pounds
we're getting the 200 000 contribution
towards play and management in the open
space
we're also getting that wasn't on offer
um
back in january and has only happened
since the
august meeting is an additional
contribution of 31
500 pounds so that residents of the
development would have access to
a 150 pound discount on the purchase of
a new
new cycle and again that's another step
to try and encourage
uh cycle use within the village and to
get people to move away from using their
cars for local journeys
we're also getting a station
contribution of thirty thousand that's
something that members wanted last time
that has been secured
so depending on how you add those
uh benefits up it's something in the
order of 1.72 million to
to over 2 million pounds worth of of
public benefit
but also what we need to do is just
think about the 35
affordable housing that's being
delivered
and you can do cash calculations in all
kinds of ways
but the bottom line is
to get 35 percent affordable housing
represents a significant public benefit
if the council were to provide those you
might expect
it to invest something like 8.8 million
to deliver 73 dwellings
this scheme would deliver those and i
might be criticized for the assumptions
that i put into those and that would be
fair enough but
it can't be denied the 73 affordable
dwellings socially represents
a fantastic public benefit when we have
so many people on the housing register
and that we need to deliver 120
houses a year affordable houses a year
up until 2036 in mid-suffolk
all sorts of other benefits that i've
listed here in terms of section 106
that we're securing the one of the
biggest things since even since august
is
the move towards these tiger crossings
and i'm sure that's something that
that councillors will want to explore as
we go through the debate
we have to accept yes there will be
cumulative impacts there will be
additional pressure on facilities
in the in the village we know that the
new primary school is coming
we know that still money will fund or
potentially fund additional
gp expansion
the parish council will be entitled to
25
of civil receipts because of the adopted
neighborhood plan
we do know that there will be additional
traffic movements but we think the
impact
will be mitigated by the enhanced
package of
improvements we know that there will be
additional
construction traffic and that will have
to be managed
we know that potentially more people
living in thurston will mean
better use of the station we're already
dealing and spending money
on resolving platform improvement
issues and there will be an additional
loss of
of farmland the scheme is still liable
on the basis of all of that we are
recommending
continuing to recommend that planning
permission be granted
subject to the prior completion of
section 106 agreement
and on that note here i hand back to you
for
the next stages of the debate thank you
very much
thank you very much for that very
comprehensive overview of the
application uh
members um only so far we've heard from
vincent
and uh i admitted in the start uh due to
my technological problems
or technology problems i'd just like to
remind everyone present this meeting is
being broadcast live so anyone that
comes on to speak following vincent
and is live on the internet and will be
capable of repeated viewings
uh the whole meeting is also being
recorded except where obviously there
are confidential exempt items
so if you make any representations to
this meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being recorded
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council under the
possible use of sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
uh the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph will
broadcast this meeting
when the public and press not lawfully
excluded and i think just for the
benefit of members
uh and the members of the public uh it's
important just to note that we have ian
de prez with us today who's our legal
advisor
we have claire philpott the government
officer we have philip isabel who's the
chief planning officer
vincent who we've heard from vincent
pierce the case officer sam harvey has
joined us today
a senior development management engineer
from suffolk county council
on the highways and we have uh obviously
the ward members who we'll hear from
later
okay so we've had a lot of information
there um and also
we've also had the late papers members
as well so happy to open it up now just
for
points of clarity around what we've
heard so far
and if you put your hand up i'll bring
you in in the order that your hand goes
up
i said just to remind you this isn't
debate it's just points of clarity
around what's been presented
first up is cancer field and if you
could turn your camera on when you speak
please
uh that would be great thank you
welcome the detail about the bumbry arms
junction that's
now much clearer but
just one question really on that area
you've obviously done traffic
simulations and you've
derived q lengths but you're telling us
that the software that does that
calculation is not clever enough to look
at the mover technology and make
predictions with that actually in place
therefore we're sort of guessing at the
improvement that may produce
have i got that right or am i
misunderstanding
i would suggest counsellor feel that
we're
we're not guessing uh we know that
signals that aren't don't have the mover
technology will deliver significant
benefits in themselves
but what we do know is that once you
install the mover system
the management technique is far more
sophisticated because it's reading
traffic in real time and changing the
lights in response
we're not guessing that that will have a
significant improvement it will have an
improvement what i'm trying to
demonstrate is that signalization
in itself has enormous benefits and with
with mover the benefits for the people
of thirst and in terms of getting
in and out of the village are
significant but the point that came
out in january was is there or is there
not sufficient capacity at that junction
and the answer is there is capacity at
that junction
with signalization to accommodate the
glebman development and with mover
technology we've even bought
further capacity and that was the
significance of that table that had the
green
green blocks in it when we looked before
there were some red blocks
and that's a point that you were keen to
understand
previously counsellor so no we're not
guessing this is
this is state of the art understanding
of
of that technology and of the benefits
of signalization
i'm sure my county colleagues could give
you a much more
scientific response but that might be a
matter for debate i'll leave that
for the chair they leave it dubai but uh
it's sort of like a stochastic update
that
you do to the traffic lights timing
and i was just seeking is there a
simulated
answer for that or an estimated answer
okay there's an estimated answer thank
you
thank you uh next up counselor stringer
thank you chair uh i've got three three
uh questions
um you you made uh you talked to great
length
about the the number of traffic arisings
at certain junctions
and you were using a calculation from
government about how
traffic numbers had been dropping i
take it you've used that in the
calculations of these junctions
but surely that's wrong to use that
statistic
because that statistic is use is
including
cities where there has been a
significant drop in in car transport
so could i be asked if the modeling if
you used
is a national one including cities or is
this a suffolk one
specific to this junctions and and the
traffic horizons we have in suffolk
when you were mentioning the affordable
housing you
use the word it'll be socially
beneficial
so can i confirm whether these are at
social rent
or affordable rent which is the usual
uh you also could could i ask why we
didn't
when we were looking at the health
provision why we didn't look
at the provision in the bacton area
because
lots of residents in backton use wall
pit surgery
even more now because bacton surgery is
actually closed
so i i i'm struggling to see why that
wasn't factored in
thank you chair okay over to vincent
thank you chair the i thought
i'll do it in a different order if i may
the 35 affordable would be expected to
comply with our
normal requirement which is the majority
of those would have to be affordable
rented
accommodation so we're currently working
on a 75
25 split so the majority is
affordable rented in terms of
pressure on health care facilities in
backton the point i'm making is that
by securing the land in woolpit
we are building in capacity to expand
the wool pit
surgery to accommodate future
demand now whether or not
considerations of bacteria is relevant
to an application in thurston
perhaps not but the answer to your point
is that
we have already secured that land we are
already thinking
ahead about ensuring that there is
adequate gp
facilities for people in that catchment
in terms of the modeling i think i would
have to defer to my
county colleagues to deal with the very
specific point you raised councillor
stringer around
the assumptions within that modeling in
terms of suffolk
movements or national movements in terms
of the
downturn in trips so at that point i
would have to
ask sam for advice
thank you chair chair can i count back
on the health one
let's should we just should we finish
off the answer the more then we'll see
if you want to come back on
all three okay thank you sam do you just
want to come in
on that point yes thank you chair um the
growth is to suffolk
what would hap what happened was that
the uh transport
consultant looked at the growth
that was predicted for 2020
from the 2017 surveys
and the transport assessments and the
growth was less than
the actual measured survey for
the march surveys
andrew do you want to come back in yeah
i think i think that clarifies the
question that we
we have aggregated the national model i
want to come back on the health issue
uh you fundamentally misunderstood the
question
already people from backton
use wool pit surgery uh
already people from elms will use
wallpaper surgery
missed out from the presentation uh
there's significant growth in both these
villages
and coupled with that the current
bactern surgery is closed
that's why i was surprised that you
saying that we've thought about
growth in health need when in fact
there's
a huge uh pent-up need that already
uh so the expansion could be
already taken care of by the numbers
from pressure elsewhere
may come back here
sorry i was on me yes please do
understand the point you're
you're making councillor stringer but as
the
planning authority we have um
minimum impact on healthcare provision
because as you know that's a matter for
the nhs and the
ccg but what we have done is
i think remarkably forward thinking
in that in warpit as part of an
application on the residential
development we have secured additional
land
to enable the health provider to expand
provision obviously if we hadn't have
secured that land they would have been
restricted to their existing
site so i think we have gone
a tremendous way further forward than
perhaps a number of planning authorities
would
would do in making sure we have the land
for expansion
it's now up to the nhs and the ccg
to ensure that that valuable asset
is best used to expand facilities we're
even using
sil money so they can even make a bid
against the silpot
to make that possible so i'm sure that
you will be making very strong
representation to
the ccg that they do dip into our
sill fund and they do take advantage of
that
uh new area of land to expand facilities
not just for thurston
but for your own people in backton
that's
something that i'm sure you'll get
behind and rally the troops with
thank you
thank you very much okay and next up is
cancer eben
um thank you very much chair um firstly
can i just
before my ask my questions can i just
make a couple of clarifications
that i understood councillor turner had
made apologies but that wasn't at the
beginning of the meeting
and also um law homes has been mentioned
several times and while this isn't a
blah holmes application
um my brother robert e burn works for
bloor home so i just wanted to
um make that um thank you yeah and and
i have had an email from turner with
something to read out on her behalf
for full transparency but thank you
vincent for a very
comprehensive presentation i've got
three
questions if i may um firstly
um with regards to icsworth road
there have been a lot of issues with
regards to the
trees along that road and i just wanted
to
ask just mentioned in s 9.4
um if that has been resolved um
secondly i understand about the station
feasibility study um but could you give
us some dates
on that as to when one when that would
report back
and then secondly um when it be likely
that any actions from that would be
implemented and thirdly if i may
um the timings as well for when
for signalization and the mover
installation at
bumbryan's junction thank you very much
thank you thank you yeah thank you
councillor eben
in terms of exworth
road we are now actively looking with
the county council
at a solution that takes that footway
cycle way behind the
the biggest tree the most important tree
so we are confident now that that tree
is not threatened
in terms of our approach to
when will signalization that the bumbry
arms happen
that's a matter for the county council
insofar as
the money that has been secured from the
first and five developments
is um growing all the time
and we'll ask sam for an indication as
to when that might happen but the idea
would be that were you
to grant planning permission for this
development
the developer would provide the funding
for mover
and the mover would be installed at the
same time as the
signalization but the signalization work
is now down
to suffolk county council so we'll ask
them for an update
in terms of the timing for the
feasibility
work at the station i haven't got the
exact
dates but i know that all parties are
working to try and come up with
something
quickly because there was a previous
feasibility study so this is a question
of
of taking the findings from that and
working up some some
fresh ideas but in terms of the actual
dates i can't give you a date at this
stage counselor because i don't have
that
information but i know that everyone is
all the parties are working together to
come up with a solution that is
quick i'm i'm something in my head is
thinking
december i'm sure christine
suggested december might be the date
where we're looking to get
answers to those questions and then
there would be a bid
in the new year for funding from the sil
pop fire cabinet but that is something
i'd have to double check on to give you
a
absolute definitive answer so apologies
that i haven't got
the exact answer but that's my
understanding thank you
thank you for that i just think the
dates are important with regards to when
this
development might commence perhaps my
colleagues behind the scenes can be
asking those questions whilst i deal
with the rest if i can
send a sort of secret coded message to
them if they're listening
i think we've heard that yeah thank you
thank you rachel
okay and next up is counselor matheson
thank you um coming back to the health
question
and thank you for pointing to pointing
out the progress at woolpit
um however i wanted to ask if you
anybody has had any recent discussions
with um
the ccg part of the nhs because i notice
on page 142
that they they were discussing the the
capacity
constraints at the two nearest surgeries
which which were of course the ones in
berry mountain farm
and um the one at x worth and um
so it does really raise some doubts
in my mind as to
whether the the right amount of planning
is going on
on the nhs side of things um these
matters are
concerns across the part of the
districts that we're talking about
and that i know and i represent so
um just just have you had a recent
discussion with them
to to see that they are actually
properly addressing capacity at all
these
relevant surgeries okay thank you
vincent as a development
management officer i wouldn't be having
those discussions
but i do know that those discussions
happen
routinely between our policy team and
our communities team now the the issue i
think for us
as a planning authority and you as
members of the referrals planning
committee is
strictly speaking those are points that
have to be dealt with by the
health authority and the ccg we have
done as much as we can
in terms of securing additional land
we also have said to west suffolk
district council and the ccgs you are
able to bid
against our sill pot if you need to
enhance gp services in your areas to
cater for people from
our district you can make a bid against
ourselves
and if it's legitimate we can make that
money available to you and that's the
benefit of us being a
a civil authority whereas our neighbours
aren't in in truth they can be
they can be bidding against our part and
we can share our part
with them if it helps our own
communities but it is something as i
said to uh councillor stringer
council madison i'm sure you will be
pressing hard you'll be using all your
influence
to perhaps even have a discussion
perhaps between you you might actually
want to have a discussion
set up a meeting with the ccg and start
to explore these issues directly
with them we're always happy to join you
on those but if it's a question of
lobbying them
then more power to your elbow and we'll
do what we can to help you
thank you did you want to come in on
this point or just
after all the members have had questions
uh
chairman bearing in mind that vince was
asking for um some
some some contributions from about
scenes i can add a little bit more to
his answer around the railway station
that's the feasibility studied there uh
to stand for christine thurlow that
the uh the expectation there is
uh that the study will start around
september and finish
uh and report back in march of 2021
and and whilst i'm on um i also was
listening to councillor matheson asking
about gp capacity i'm aware that
uh west suffolk dealt with an
application fairly recently to expand
the surgery in stanton
uh and indeed i believe there are there
is
uh county council discussions going on
with west suffolk about uh that stanton
surgery and
the potential to expand provision in
that area which obviously
might well add to capacity uh to support
the wider uh
the wider health authority needs in this
locality thank you chairman thank you
very much thank you
next up is cancer guthrie oh yes thank
you very much
um chair i think some of it has been
sort of a question but anyway i'll just
move on to it
um regarding um the bunbury arms should
this application not be approved
presumably we lose the 30 000
obviously from this application and does
that also mean that the funding for
mover is dropped off the pot as well
please thank you yes
thank you okay uh we have
no other questions at this point now we
normally i always think it's important
to try and have a bake about every 90
minutes
and i think actually now it'd be a good
time to have a quick 10 minute break
uh so that people can quickly stretch
their legs
we'll come back at 10 past 11 which is
only nine minutes actually
and then we will start with the public
speakers
and after the public speakers obviously
then go into debate so
can i just remind everyone please not to
discuss the application during
the quick mini break literally we want
to start very promptly at 11
10 so we'll just suspend the meeting for
nine minutes so people can have a quick
stretch thank you and use comfort have a
comfort break thank you
hopefully coming back so promptly um
just before we continue
uh where we open it up for public
speakers we just need to
everyone is back before we go into that
next session
claire over to you please thank you
chair councillor james kesten
president councillor rachel ebern
present councillor john field
president councillor peter gould
president councillor kathy guthrie
present council of liberia hattingham
president councillor matthew hicks
president
councillor john matherson president
councillor andrew mellon
present councillor richard mayer
president council dave muller
present councillor mike norris present
councillor andrew stringer president and
councillor roland warboys
president thank you chair thank you very
much okay
so now we move on to public speakers and
we now like to ask the parish council
representative uh derek haley uh to
speak
uh you have three minutes in which to
address the committee
and if you could turn your camera on
please
i think it is on actually uh bless you
um right i'll start the councils will
will be aware that the parish council
through its legal
team contend that the committee members
were significantly received by planning
officers
planning referrals committee meeting on
the 29th of january
in their advice given to them on a
relative weight to be accorded to the
may
thurston neighborhood plan on 25th of
october compare
with the examined unexamined let alone
adopted consultation drove global plan
your office has still conveniently
chosen to hone in on use
their own interpretation of the word
focus thereby giving them the reason for
recommending further growth in person
which can't regardless of the impact
that this will have on the village
as a whole and with no regards to all
the wording contained within the
thurston ndp it has yet to be adopted by
your council
this interpretation is to be subject to
judicial review for
both applications submitted planning
meeting but the parish council
recommends that this application should
be reviewed
has been contributed to the policy
contained with thousand
ndp and particularly policy one first
invasive
chassis and the main ndp
further the lack of consideration of
traffic impacts
from sites t1 to ta up to 2024
of the crossroads junction of tacoma
equals road
located in payton we're not convinced of
the
uh the technology of untried and
unproven
mover why has the modelling
not been extended to include school
collection hours given that one of the
key considerations to the person
being free service center is its
community college which is currently
split over two
sites and generates different amount of
traffic outside of those peak hours
the impact of the of the increased
growth of a narrow
rural road on a stressed rural road
that will be significantly impacted by
not only the persimmon
development opposite but also the
application by suffolk county
for a community school artificial pitch
car parking to the rear of the college
approval of this application at this
point is the village will result
in daily vehicle joins in excess of six
citizens
along this road why why has there been
that you have updated about the seal so
my apologies
the latest traffic reception so
underestimated the effects on the bum
ramps given the assessment was made in
early march
and pc has concerned over the accuracy
of such
data climate change the proposal
demonstrates no measures to disclose the
use of cars for residents
to travel to work the use of vehicles to
access
employing outside of the village as this
proposal fails to offer any employment
opportunities
will increase congestion and combat
carbon emissions
should this application be approved
parish council questions
in msdc's the desire to respond
positively
to the climate change challenge and to
gauge effectively
coherently with the ndp i would also
like to stress
that i'm if in respect of the
neighborhood plan
if you accept these recommendations
then i have to understand what
what your take is or neighborhood land
you seem to
abandon neighborhood plants at your will
when it's convenient
and it's amazing how all this money has
suddenly appeared out of the blue
uh before eve from what was to now
and so we will question why some of this
is there is
there and still thank you yes matthew
sorry i was just i thought you i was
just thanking you because i thought you
just finished
sorry messi oh yeah that's a switch page
just in case i
missed something okay thank you
well no i i mean it's the the railway
question um the three minutes are up uh
all right okay thank you
okay and do we have any questions for
the parish council if you'd like to have
any questions if you put your hand up
cancer stringer first
thank you chair just one question uh if
this were approved today
what would you think the impact of that
approval would have
on the maid neighborhood plan
i i think i think it would have a big
impact
because we we would say to ourselves
well
why are we do why are we making
neighborhood plans when they are
completely
being pushed shy uh at
uh convenient to developers
okay next up is council eben
thank you very much chair i think um
this is a question for an officer really
but it's arisen from um
what derek haley has just said to the
committee is just the
um significance of the neighborhood plan
um
with regards to this application i know
we've the presentation from the office
has focused on
on the addition from the previous
committee of the highways improvements
and so forth
but um could um the officer and i can
see
philippe spells just put up his hand um
just give us a
firm kind of confirmation as it were of
the relationship of this site
to thurston's neighborhood plan and our
draft
emerging plan which is still draft and
still emerging thank you very much
did you want to come in on that point
yes if i may chairman thank you yes um
and uh to try and simplify and explain
the uh the made first and neighborhood
plan is part of your development plan so
uh in law in essence uh decisions should
be made in accordance with the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
so uh you have a planning policy
in the neighborhood plan i'm just trying
to locate it on my
screen uh although i seem to have
closed it down so uh two seconds
the um policy one of that
um uh plan talks about focusing growth
in thurston
forgive me i did have it up two seconds
ago and i managed to have closed it
talks about focusing growth in thurston
and it talks about the district council
being the authority to
effectively identify the strategic
direction
for uh for housing growth
um uh and that in essence puts things
back to us that comes up in paragraph
three
four point two of uh of of the
neighborhood plan
so effectively we have uh a measure of
inconsistency i suppose in approach
but the first neighborhood plan
recognizes that the district has a role
to plan strategically for housing
and obviously we understand the the
limited way that we can attach to the
jlp in its present format but clearly it
represents a direction of travel that
the council as a whole has agreed and so
you are in the territory of how you
weigh the material considerations here
so
this is a question of of considerable
importance the starting point is that
on the face of it the neighborhood plan
is the development part of the
development plan
and is recently made however that is not
the end of that conversation because
policy one in that plan
uh specifically just uses the word focus
the focus is not an exclusive term there
is some separately a policy on
development outside settlement
boundaries
but there is also a recognition within
the plan
that the district has a role in planning
strategically for housing and that
thurston should play its part in that
so both of those things come together
and in essence you have a plan which
acknowledges that
the district has a duty to
deal with with things on a strategic
level the tension and conflict is
inevitably why we are here at committee
because on the face of it you could
quite justifiably say this
is a challenge to the approach the
neighborhood plan would expect
to take but from our point of view
we don't apprehend the neighborhood plan
to be at odds with the strategic
direction of the district and the
strategic direction of the district
is and needs to accommodate housing
uh for its its identified housing need
um
and so to that extent we are in the
territory of
weighing up material considerations
against that neighborhood plan
uh without reference to the document
chairman actually i need to get up in
two seconds that's probably as far as i
can take you just for the moment
okay okay may i just come back because i
found
well sorry i've been looking trying to
look in the previous pages
um that there's a point that says all
new development in thirst and
power shall be focused within the
settlement boundary
but it's my understanding um
is saying that if it's a strategic
needed the district
that effectively outweighs the
neighborhood plans allocations
um if i can come back on that chairman
so
the word focused within uh policy 1a
is important um and i think this is not
a question of
uh does not all this is about judgment
this is what this committee
must focus must identify and weigh up
uh the district has a responsibility and
its plans are not up to date
uh and consistent with the nppf so the
district is in a position regarding its
approach to
uh addressing its housing need the
parish council's
plan uh ident recognizes that it
that the village should play its part in
contributing to
uh housing need across the district and
will need to play that
and that's described within paragraph
4.2 of the neighborhood plan
and then uses the language of focus now
it is true to say that uh further policy
uh further policy within the
neighborhood plan
uh talks about development outside
settlement boundaries has presently
identified
being for specific purposes but you are
in the core of a tension between
differing differing policy elements here
and material considerations
and my advice to committee is that the
housing need that we have across the
district
uh the status of uh at the council's
direction of travel
albeit of limited weight in in the
format of the jlp
are persuasive elements to place greater
weight on that
notwithstanding the provision that you
have
within policy one which arguably does
not of itself
preclude development outside the
settlement boundary if that is
appropriate and accepting
that the policy within thurston's
neighborhood plan
does describe limited exceptions we are
in the territory very much as i say of
significance of material considerations
and the weight that
members attached to them in this
committee meeting thank you very much
for that
thank you okay uh
we did have another hand up that's gone
down that's at the moment we don't have
any more
questions for the parish council so
thank you very much
derek for joining us um we don't have an
objector
or a supporter uh as my understanding is
that still the case please
claire yes that's correct yeah
okay thank you so we'll now move on to
the uh
agent and the applicant so
again uh please if you turn your camera
on
hopefully you can hopefully you can hear
and see me now yeah
thank you okay and again if you can keep
three minutes please
yes um thank you good morning members
and my name is stuart carville i'm a
planning manager at global developments
um following the committee in january um
you asked us to look at a number of
matters
um which mr pierce has set out for you
we've responded to your concerns
around the landscaping and the linkages
through the site
principally however we reviewed the
bumble arms junction
to provide additional information and
modelling in order to demonstrate how
the junction would work with movements
arising from this proposal as well as
all the other developments
in thurston already permitted and in
response to a question asked
of the officer earlier the growth is
predicted based upon local data
including
existing travel to work patterns and not
national trends discussed
and this is locally adjusted to the ward
level and we use a rural growth factor
um in in generating the vehicle
movements mie not an urban one or
somewhere such as london um the scheme
is expected to generate approximately 14
vehicles through the bumby arms junction
bumpery arms junction in the am peak and
11 in the pm peak
um we've shown with the synchronization
um at bumby arms junctions there will be
there will be capacity
including the scheme we are offering
offering to provide demand responsive
movement
for a benefit of all users of the bumbry
arms junctions in a demand responsive
system
and as councillor ebon pointed out um
castle guthrie sorry pointed out that
this won't be delivered
and without the funding from this scheme
this application has provided
significant range of measures to help
promote encourage and enable sustainable
transport
within the village including new table
top calming um zebra or
andor tiger crossings and toucan
crossings cycle vouchers for new
residents
cycle links across the sites on plot uh
indwelling facilities for cycles
electric vehicle charging points as well
as contributions to a community cut
community car club in the village the
site is in accordance with emerging
local plans requirements and it is
compliant with all the policies
in the thurston neighborhood plan um as
the members resolved
when considering the base and road
scheme which had the same site status as
this one
it will deliver community infrastructure
of the neighborhood plan that no other
application has done to date
through extensive play areas community
growing spaces as well as the 74 or four
dwellings
sorry 74 affordable dwellings for real
people and a real need of a home who
might not have one
cloudman is committed to providing all
these facilities
and benefits for all those who live and
visit in thurston already
complementing what's what has already
been approved in terms of sustainability
packages
sustainability sorry in providing
comprehensive package for the whole
village
there is evidence now that there is
capacity in the highway network for the
vehicles to be absorbed and we will
provide the safety and
sustainability package set out
um therefore the scheme is compliant
with development plan there is no severe
highways impact and we are providing
significant safety and improvements
across the whole village
and therefore respectfully requests that
you grant permission on the scheme
thank you thank you very much uh
questions uh for the applicant agent uh
first of all
uh cancer matheson
thank you yes you've said that the um
the mover technology would only be
delivered
um with this with this development
and in fact mr pierce did um also say
that earlier to
to a question um but
surely there are there are developments
in west suffolk the other side of the
boundary
and indeed the arms itself must surely
be in west suffolk
um is it not perfectly possible that
some other development which which is
generating traffic
for this junction um could also
say oh well if you're going to put the
traffic lights in there
that would be a useful addition um
in our section 106 claim on on our um
application in in that's coming to us in
in great barn
um well no one's off no one there's no
offer as i understand it
to provide it um in providing it through
this scheme
um if this when this scheme is built out
there's an opportunity to provide it now
um but when the scheme starts to come
forward
and what that would mean is that it can
be installed at the first signalization
stage so
if the signals are installed um as a
standard
four-way crossing um and then mover is
funded at a later date but there is no
evidence of where that funding is going
to come from without this site
it would require the road to be dug up
again and cause significant disruption
for a second time and you know i
affected the
second installation of the lights so by
providing it now through this scheme
it's a benefit to the scheme and
everybody uses that junction on a daily
basis
thank you cancer stringer
just wanted a point of clarity you
mentioned about the affordable homes
that it would
provide homes for those that don't have
them
uh i would like to remind you that we
see
mid-suffolk has no one without a home at
the moment and we haven't
since the outbreak of covid19
i think i'm not quite sure there was a
question that is questions at the moment
but
we'll take that thank you any other
questions
okay thank you very much uh we now move
over to the ward members
uh and we have two board members now um
council bridgeton would you like to go
first or second
because the other one is a red report um
i'm happy to go go first if that's okay
of course
okay over to you lovely thank you very
much
chair um i i think i'll just first start
by saying that i do recognize that
there's been an awful lot of work that's
gone into this application since it
since it last became uh came before the
planning committee in january
um so i would like to thank planning
officers for that it seems that there's
an awful lot
um of input that's been received
particularly
with regards to landscaping uh
biodiversity
cycling the new tiger crossings so i do
recognize that and i think we should
thank planning officers for the amount
of
thought that they've put into this um
notwithstanding what i've just said
though that i do is the ward member
object to this application and do ask
that the referrals committee
refuse planning permission in this
instance um i've got a few points
um that i'll touch upon and broadly they
uh cover the reasons why the uh
referrals committee was minded to refuse
in the first instance back in january
um first as i think we've already
touched upon there is that conflict
between
this application and what's in uh
thurston's neighborhood neighborhood
development plan
um i do accept absolutely that thurston
is a key service center um
no doubt about that and we are expected
to accommodate development and i think
we can say that we have um but what i
will touch upon though is this
this precise policy conflict um because
i
i do also accept that policy 1a does use
the word focus
and the focus is not an exclusionary
term but i would just point out that it
the context of that is then expanded and
elaborated on in policy 1d
which says that planning out or
development outside of the settlement
boundary
will need to demonstrate that no
available and deliverable sites exist
within the settlement boundary
so i think that's quite an important
context when considering what it state
what it says in in 1a around the focus
because i don't think there has been any
assessment or any evidence provided
that there are no available and
deliverable sites within the boundary
which is where that focus should be
so on that i think it's an important
context to remember when considering
um the weight i say it is a question of
judgment the weight that you do give
the neighborhood development plan given
that that is recently adopted and
um full plan i would ask you to give
give weight to that
um another aspect of what was discussed
previously was the
potential railway improvements the lack
of clarity about that and yes it's
absolutely true that
the feasibility study went before
cabinet last week and we granted
still funding for that feasibility
feasibility study
but i would just emphasize it is exactly
that it's a feasibility study
we don't yet know the outcome of that
study we don't know what the design of
those improvements will look like
we don't even know if those improvements
can be delivered and one point in
particular i'd like to
just flag to your attention is the fact
that there's still a lack of clarity of
who owns the land below the um
the train station platform so we don't
even know whether we would have the
consent of the owner and delivering
those improvements
and linking that southern platform with
bayton road um
in addition there's also the this
question around highways
so in the first iteration of the report
obviously
there was this debate over the severity
of the impact
and the updated report says that there
are still negative impacts in the form
of increased traffic
and that the mover uh modeling will just
be an estimation of the benefits and i
think it's important to consider that
um there's something else i'd like to
just draw your attention to which is a
recent
um appeal decision that happened within
my ward in the village of norton
in the halls lane application this was
another site much smaller than this one
admittedly
but whether the main debate was around a
question of
of the um severity of the impact on
highways
now the local highways authority in
suffolk county council and officers
recommended that we approve that
planning application because there was
no severe impact on highways the
committee
disagreed with that they rejected it on
highways grounds
that then went to appeal but the
planning inspector
disagreed with the assessment of the
local highways authority he thought that
there was
severe impact on highways so what i
would say is that
and the inspector actually made this
clear in his recommendation in his
conclusion sorry
that it is not the committee is not
obliged to accept
assessments from highways authorities
they can disagree with them if they
think in their judgment the impact is
severe
and given the accumulative impact of all
the developments in thurston i would
argue
that there should be given weight to
what those what exact
negative impacts this additional
development will have and whether or not
that can be mitigated by what is effect
an estimation of benefit
um and lastly there is just one other
point i'd like to emphasize which is the
impact on residential amenity
because this has been sort of raised
briefly but i think we should give it
um more consideration than has been thus
far because from what we've experienced
already in thirsting with a couple of
the sites
under construction we've already had
significant significant
impacts on the roads within thurston
particularly we've talked about meadow
lane but also this oak lane barrels road
as well
all of that is as i say just the impact
from a couple of sites under development
so when you consider
the accumulative impact of all of those
other settlements under construction
sorry other developments under
construction
i think the impact will be severe as
well and will have a detrimental impact
on residential amenity
and so just to conclude based on all of
those
reasons um cumulative reasons i would
urge the planning committee
uh to refuse this development going
forward and i'm happy to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you very much uh council guthrie
you have a question
uh yes i do thank you sorry i'm getting
my buttons muddled up
um you mentioned 1d
um regarding the neighborhood plans
saying that there were no um available
deliverable sites that exist
um does thurston have such a site that
could take the capacity that's being
offered
which would give the benefits to the
community
so the way the word is phrased in policy
one d is that there would need to be a
demonstration that there were sites
in thurston that could accomplish can i
cut across you are there
such sites that would give this capacity
i don't know not a single one i don't
imagine but that would be for
that's what the assumption of the policy
is that there would need to be the
applicant demonstrating that
this application should go ahead outside
of the settlement boundary
because they have demonstrated that they
can't deliver it within the boundaries
the answer to my question is no okay
thank you
thank you any other questions for the
ward member nope okay
thank you very much and the other board
member is councillor wendy turner who as
we know is unable to be here today
and she has sent a piece through for me
to read out a report through for me to
read out
application dc1902090
as i'm not able to attend this committee
meeting i'd like to submit this letter
in opposition to the planning
application
cited above i would also like to request
that a site visit which includes site
visits to the various junctions that
will be
impacted as stated in the revise
application
is carried out as the highways are
integral to this application
please do accept my apologies for my
absence i am writing in support of
thurston parish council and their
objection to the proposed planning
application
the proposed development plan is a
further 200 houses on a road that is
already under great stress from
persimmon
development on the opposite side
currently there are only a handful of
houses on this section of road
but when all the developments are
complete there will be a minimum of 450
houses
at least 1200 more people with the
associated number of vehicles
each vehicle is estimated to have five
journeys per day
twelve hundred times five equals six
thousand vehicle movements along
sorry vehicle journeys along that road
the ixworth road is narrow winding
country road not designed for 450 houses
and related vehicles
as stated by pakenham pc the ixworth
road
is the main route for children going to
the primary school
and upper schools from pakenham but
equally significantly
it is now a cut through for traffic
coming from the a143 trying to avoid the
bumbry arms crossroads
combined with scc's decision to stop
funding bus passes for out-of-catchment
children
there is predicted to be a further 600
cars entering the village each day
taking collecting children to and from
school
for an ecological standpoint and bearing
in mind the recent protests and
objections by local residents and
environmental activists to the removal
of the
an old oak tree it is worth noting that
the proposed removal of scrub
and a short section of an established
hedgerow as noted in the planning
committee referral papers
page 212 s 9.11
is more valuable than implied there is
current research that has found scrub to
be an extremely important habitat for
the development of saplings
thurston has an adopted neighborhood
development plan that is that was shown
to hold weight in a recent planning
committee
when an application for a proposed
application for a house outside the
settlement boundary
was refused unanimously by one
abstention
as policy one of the document clearly
states
that all new development in thurston
parish shall be focused within the
settlement boundary
this outcome clearly shows that
thurston's
neighborhood development plan must be
given appropriate weight in this case
during the time of a declared climate
and biodiversity emergency
and even more immediately a pandemic i
feel we need to pause while we take
stock of increased housing density and
its likely impact on the current and
future residents of thurston
and its neighboring villages there are
already five major developments approved
leading to 1200 more houses
i'm not advocating the blocking of
development and am aware that thurston
is a core village
but the physical impact of having all
these developments happening together is
detriment detrimental to the current
residents well-being
thank you for your time and i urge you
to refuse this application
counselor wendy turner first and ward
okay members um so that's
all the information that's been
presented to us um what i
propose to do is um just to run through
uh maybe uh if each person wants to
speak
maybe we could go through it in an order
or if we can do it by hands i'm very
relaxed it's really what i would say is
if each person just speaks once
maybe if we just run through
alphabetically so that everyone comes in
and can give their comments and do it
that way otherwise it's going to be hard
for me to know if people have come in
more than once
so um if everyone's happy i'll just do
it alphabetically
and then maybe next time if we do it
again maybe i'll do it reverse so
uh counselor castin do you want to start
off as we're now into debate
thank you very much mr chairman i can
see a lot of
police positive things in this
application the
the mover which modeling looks like it's
can help the um congestion on the
um junction there the tiger crossings
make the junction
a lot safer um for the just you
generally get distracted young people um
in that area it's a lot clearer for the
drivers
coming the other way the railway path um
is an improvement as well
the um the site is 10 dwellings per acre
roughly
um which i think is a good density
it's got a large green space area i like
the 20 meter buffer
on the roadside and i like the green
links as well
and also the orbital footpath
but we do have some pretty big issues
here
um the um the settlement boundary
that councilor richardson um makes a
very good argument that
the um developer has not demonstrated
that this housing need can be provided
for
within that settlement boundary it's a
really difficult thing to actually do
unless you have control over that land
because um
if there's a question of whether that
land
is available or not or whether it exists
or not
but um i i think that um that is a good
argument
um the um
the um the the it's allocated in the
draft local plan but obviously this is
in conflict with the thurston um
neighborhood plan
um the big question here is does the uh
thurston neighborhood plan um
deliver the housing needs of a key
service
center like thurston um i think that's
what
the we need to um get to the bottom of
in this debate
there's also issues on the
the cumulative increase in this village
and what that does the road system but
um i look forward to um hearing how
other councils
um feel about that and other issues they
bring to our attention thank you
council ebon would you like to come in
at this point
um thank you very much chair i was
hoping we were going to do this by
hand but maybe that wouldn't do that
next time um firstly
i think on this application we've seen
the significant changes that have
happened since it was last presented to
us
and i thank officers and for working to
do that
but that does really show what happens
when we question it
as councillors when we question um you
know what is this
development bringing to um a community
and um i wish that those
we you know we didn't have to do so many
questions i wish applicants would
actually come forward
with um applications that
have got um the type of things that have
been improved
upon on this particular site however
i've i've interestingly when i first
read these papers i was thinking
oh you know it's so much better you know
perhaps
it's you know straightforward case now
but
as i've listened through the debate i'm
i'm more sitting on the right the debate
but the questions and presentation
i'm actually more on the fence than i
than i was before um
particularly coming back to um
infrastructure delivery it seems that we
we have to prove housing delivery but
not infrastructure delivery
and i'm very concerned that even still
in the recommendations
we've got um things like there's a plan
that will come forward that will will
say about highway works and so on
and it's it's a wet it's it's not a
there's nothing with
definite timings on it and again we tend
to get seeming to get
a lot of housing but the infrastructure
comes at a later date so i'm really
concerned that
um this isn't really very definite
on the delivery of infrastructure and
i've
particularly got concerns about the
neighborhood plan i just wish the
minister for housing robert generic
would actually
come forward and actually really stand
up for neighborhood plans
um because this is not in the
neighborhood plan
the cabinet at mid suffolk agreed this
neighborhood plan
and um we should be standing by it but
that said
it doesn't seem that we're ever
presented by planning officers
um with with that as an option
and just you know on housing delivery
thurston's neighborhood plan
as well as the developments are
currently there is providing
huge amounts of numbers of housing for
the thurston
um and we do have a significant amount
of planning commissions
um in um mid-suffolk i think the
consultation on
on the housing um five-year land supply
said even even taking a thousand
permissions out of it we've got 7.67
years worth
um of housing in in mid-suffolk um
so what what kind of consideration do we
give that within this discussion
um but i think overall um chair my my
points
i'm pleased to see the the amendments
have been
made to this application um and
but i am still remain concerned that
it's not in
um not compliant with the neighborhood
plan and that we're
it's still not really clear about
infrastructure delivery particularly the
highways
ones and when when any work might ever
happen
at the railway station so i will
listen to my colleagues and make my mind
up in due course
thank you very much chair thank you very
much um
council field would you like to go next
yes um i i think i too
i'm in a position where one would really
like to support the neighbourhood plan
we persuade communities to produce those
um
because we and i guess even the
government believes that local people
should have
a substantial influence on development
in their area however i do find that
that
plan at the moment does not support the
latest
uh numbers that we have to deliver
knowing the required housing delivery
and when i say that actually it's the
last iteration of that
that it doesn't meet let alone the one
that's on the
on the blocks now
so if we stick to the neighborhood plan
we have a substantial problem with lack
of housing delivery
in my view we're told the neighborhood
plan
points to other sites within the
development boundary of thurston
but i've got no evidence that there are
such sites
that would deliver this quantum of
housing
so to continue the the site itself is
between two others
it fills in a a lump of a sort of dog
leg in a boundary if you like
it does seem to have good links to the
the rest of thurston the schools
and to the railway station it has some
environmental
benefits there are various buffers
invented and green
corridors which certainly are much more
beneficial than they were
on previous occasions of previous
iterations of this plan
so it clearly has a range of benefits
i also noticed that the the bumbry arms
developments that was an area where we
really felt that
we were just not getting sufficient
detail that highways had taught the
problem through
and that we had a deliverable scheme
we had some imagination at my estimation
at previous meetings but we now seem to
have that
quite adequately detailed uh you know
it's clearly not in existence and we
don't have an absolute guarantee that
anybody would get through
and build the um carry out modifications
but
it seems to me that the technological
stuff has been done pretty thoroughly
um and uh there's no earthly reason why
there shouldn't be a delivery
the cash is available to do that
the one that still leaves me with
considerable doubt i guess
is the station there we seem to have a
process that wanders
on and on and on there are set of
things that need to be determined but
they to my mind are relatively simple
even things like who does the land
belong to
could we compulsory purchase it if the
owner is is not forthcoming with a
reasonable price for
for converting that land to um station
access
we just don't seem to get anywhere
despite the pa
passage of a considerable number of
months and we're now told
it's going to take another six months to
get to the end of a feasibility study
give me strength i'm inclined to say so
i i feel at the moment that this scheme
is
has been thoroughly thought through now
that's a
pleasant change from future previous
iterations and i am inclined to support
it
i will nevertheless listen to other
counselors
and see what i have judged correctly or
misjudged
thank you thank you very much um
councillor gould would you like to go
next
thank you very much uh chair i'd like to
start by
thanking vincent for his uh presentation
which was
uh comprehensive even by his own
uh by his own standards and and there
as others have said there's clearly been
some very considerable progress
made uh since this was previously
uh before us um and
that progress has uh is offering
substantial public benefits which again
vincent has uh has has described
in his presentation and on that front
i'd
take uh councillor eben's uh
uh point that uh you know it
it gives a sense of the value of the
democratic side of this process
if through questioning uh and and
challenging
uh application what's on offer can be
improved
in a way that it has been
and and those what is on offer there
those improvements
are reliant on us um
approving at this application i i can
well understand the concerns
uh about the apparent conflicts between
the
neighborhood development plan and the
strategic housing needs that are kind of
uh emerging through work on the joint
local plan
and and an increase
more pressure is probably in prospect as
a result of the
of the planning reforms and and targets
that come
with that um but i don't think that if
we were to
refuse this application on the basis of
too much housing
uh as it were that we would be
do well to succeed in that argument at
us appeal i hear what
council richardson says about
the policy within the neighborhood
development plan
and looking at prioritizing sites within
within the settlement boundary but
though
as has been said um we don't
those sites haven't been identified in
in any case
we can only look at the application
that's
that's before us thank you very much
chair
thank you councillor guthrie
thank you for that um well i i
hopefully don't repeat too many of the
things that people might have said
earlier but
um i've been listening to the debate um
and
i've had input and read many many papers
and briefings and while i'm talking i
wonder if vince could just put up
the plan which shows where this sits
within all the other plans that are that
are
going ahead um i've listened to the
local community and i've read many
emails which have been sent to me
as of all of us um and i've listened to
the ward member
and neighborhood plans are are a big
part of our future
but as it just has been explained and i
asked the questions could we find the
alternative sites
and at the moment that really is almost
an impossible um
request we are looking at this
application um i think much of the
improvement
has been excellent and i do hope that
the community feel that they have
been listened to with the um concerns of
people
um the bunbury arms i know that area
quite well
and i think providing we can get all the
additional improvements down there i
wonder if we can get them through
earlier i don't know how that might
happen
um the railway line um i think
councillor feels summed it up really is
that we are sort of slowly going through
there but
it's not insurmountable we could there
could be some compulsory purchase there
could be some
improvements there and with a hundred
thousand that we've got from mid-suffolk
going into there
that really needs to move forward pretty
quickly
um we can't keep questioning every time
another planning application
comes before us and say no we don't like
this we don't like that
um but we've had the opportunity on in
this instance to to have a couple of uh
requests
so suffice it to say there are so many
benefits
and that i will be supporting this thank
you
councillor hattingham
thank you um alright like many others um
feel that the improvements and the
enhancements on this have been um
have been brilliant and it's a shame
they didn't come up beforehand
you know i hear what harry says about
the the neighborhood plan
and and i've said this before you know i
hate going against the religious
neighborhood plans
but i think the the connectivity to this
site for the rest of the village is
excellent it has it has got developments
both sides of it
it's a very sustainable um location
the and the for cycling and walking it's
um excellent
i like the improved um green corridor
down the center
i like the improved buffers um i think
that the improvements at bunbury arms
would be excellent and with the mover
system you know that would be
you know a really good improvement for
the area and like i say you know
it's something that you know anyone that
goes to berry is going to you know
appreciate
um the the two zebra crossings is
obviously going to be a safety issue
which is
also excellent and um yeah i i think
that you know it's a really good
application now
thank you thank you cancer matheson
sorry sorry right chair um sorry about
the delay there
um yeah like counsellor ebern
um it's it's interesting to see um
the benefits we've had from from
deferring the site
previously although remembering that in
january
we were recommended approval um
it just shows that it it could have been
improved and has been improved which is
good um
the i've i'll share the doubts about the
station
uh it is quite difficult
to to solve the problem um
we'll see what the feasibility study
says but it doesn't
guarantee a solution unfortunately but
my main
my main issue with this really is that
the
the identified housing need
we're working with some some very
contentious methodology which has come
up with some very large numbers
that um we're in the middle of wrestling
with
in terms of the joint local plan and um
the really
the there is not a need to actually
deliver sights
and decisions to fill up the numbers
that are
being calculated um but you know by the
end of next year
we actually we've actually got um until
2036 to find um and build
all these houses so
the the question of alternative sites
that might might become available um i'd
point to the windfall
um where we've we've actually
each year we find a substantial number
of
um of sites that were not allocated and
weren't
um recognized previously um which
which turn into into houses across the
district in in
all sorts of different places and um
so i i think that there is not that
great
rush now i
i know what councillor richardson said
um about the neighborhood plan
the point is policy number one is
that is not the be all and end all
it is refined by subsequent policies
um notably the one that says within the
settlement boundary
and so i think we have to
take that qualification of the general
intention of policy number one into
consideration
and finally i would say
in making a judgment about this
we we should bear in mind that one of
the three legs of sustainability in the
eyes of the mppf
is actually social sustainability and
the the speed
the likely speed let us say at the
moment
of the expansion of thurston is
is going to really strain the cohesion
of that community because there will be
huge numbers of new people um
trying to find their feet and get get
involved in the community
and that's not a fast process it's a
slow process
so that's why i would point to the fact
that the
the identified need is to be bet met
between now and 2036
um not immediately thank you
thank you council matheson um councillor
mellon would you like to go next
yes thank you chair um i probably should
just point out that i wasn't on
a planning committee when this
application came up previously
so um i'm sort of coming to it afresh
um having not been part of the previous
discussions
um and i find myself um
in sort of two minds about it because
obviously there's clearly
a lot of things which uh would recommend
this site
in terms of its proximity to the center
of thurston
um a lot of the measures that have been
outlined but i still have some
concerns um
the highways people have said that the
road impact
is no longer severe but i'm sort of
wondering what it is
is it moderate is it considerable is it
chronic
there's obviously some continuing impact
even with
the measures that have been proposed
um to my mind you know knowing that area
fairly well
the bunbury arms junction although
potentially
a pinch point is only one of a number of
junctions that will be affected by the
increased
traffic in and around thurston
and though i welcome the the proposed
changes there and the upgrade there
um i don't see that we can condition it
on this
application it's something we don't have
in our control
um turning to the health center impact
at wall pit obviously the increased
capacity there is welcome
again but there are huge numbers of
houses coming to elmswell and wall pit
who will
be the primary users of that health
facility
and again we can't condition
an increase in capacity there on this
application
um the improvements to the railway
station it would be great to see those
coming forward faster but again we can't
condition them
as far as i understand it on this
application
um so i think we come back to the point
that phil
as isabelle made which is that we're on
the kind of horns of a dilemma
in terms of policy uh we have on the one
hand
the thurston neighborhood plan and then
on the other hand
the sort of the district policy and
where those two
conflict um so i'm interested to hear a
bit more of the debate
um councillor richardson as always makes
a very
cogent argument in favor of turning this
down
but uh that's all i have to say for now
thank you
thank you very much uh next up is
council mayor
thank you chair um i too was not
involved in
the last time this came before um the
referral committee
um and i i have to say it's benefited
from the scrutiny
that has been given this plan and the
plan itself i think is
has a lot to commend it um
the neighborhood plan is an interesting
one
um but we
as a district have been given um targets
to build houses
and indeed we pass those down and set
targets
for um different centres key service
centers like thurston
and i don't i don't see how the
neighborhood plan can
can almost draw up the wagons and
refuse to get involved so um i i think
saying that development should happen
within
um the settlement boundary well i can't
see just from a quick check of the map
and
the aerial photographs i can't see where
400 houses are gonna go so i'm
i'm not sure the neighborhood plan
actually um holds water
the strategic infrastructure
that worries me um we generate the money
the money is available and that does not
mean that
the health service or the surgeries or
indeed
any of this comes to fruition and it
would be very nice to
condition this approval on the
highways infrastructure improvements and
indeed
an increase to um the warpit health
facilities though
as a key service center i don't see why
thurston shouldn't have his own
health service um facility the uh
the mother software intrigues me i
i couldn't help but have a visage a
little in my mind's eye
among them monday morning where the
software's failed
and what chaos would occur with the
lights
hopefully there's a fallback system that
would allow it to function
um should that active system fire when
that every active system does fail
it is a logical infill and i
particularly like
the fact that this is one of the few um
planning
applications that's come before us where
someone could actually live without a
car
and work in cambridge or work in london
and i don't think
um we should underestimate the positive
impacts
climate change that someone using a bike
rather than a car can have and this is
um one such
planning application so i in balance i
i'm in favor i think the the proposal
is a sound one and i think um i will be
supporting it
thank you thank you councilman muller uh
thank you chair
um yes i've listened to my colleagues
speaking
and i do actually agree with a lot of
what has been said
i do think this is a considerable
improvement to what we actually saw
back in january i i think both the
applicant
and the planning department done a
fantastic job to try and get all these
different things actually included in
the sort of recommendation
i i did have one point really that was
mentioned in the
ward members statement a councillor
turner's statement
regarding each vehicle is estimated to
have five journeys per day based on 450
homes
1200 people six thousand journeys a day
i do question that because obviously
that seems to be more subjective rather
than objective
but on the whole um yes i do like the
revised plan
and i feel that i can support this thank
you chair
thank you um counselor norris
thank you uh obviously a lot of
positive work has gone into refining
this application
to meet the points raised in the
january committee meeting
whilst i fully agree that we should
support neighbourhood plans
however the thurston neighborhood plan
does not appear to meet the identified
housing requirement for thurston
uh it is rather difficult
to come down on either side regarding
this application
but i am struggling to find identifier
to identify rather defensible planning
reasons for
refusing this application and therefore
i am inclined to support it
however i will listen to the rest of the
debate
thank you thank you very much
uh casa stringer uh thank you chair
uh first and i start from the
policy position of the most recent and
heaviest weight document that we should
be using
in determining this application and that
document is the maid
thurston neighborhood plan it's the last
document to go through an inspection
and indeed a referendum of those of
which
any development will have impact on is
the most
up-to-date document for the
determination this plan education and
the one that i will be giving
the most weight this application site is
not within the defined boundary of that
plan
we agreed that plan the community agreed
that plan
the government agreed that plan if we
didn't like it we should have said so
then
so should the government uh it isn't
even a reserve site
uh in that plan and actually could be a
reserve
site even when the plan has to be
reviewed because within
five years neighborhood plans have to be
reviewed
so the correct policy way of looking at
this should be
to refuse this site now because it's not
in the settlement boundary
but if the housing numbers are not
delivered
and by the way mid-suffolk's delivering
7.14
against five-year housing land supply at
the moment if we don't
deliver the numbers required by
government it can form part of an
orderly review and we can work with that
community
to deliver this site if if it is needed
the case officer at the start said uh
that
thurston is a core service center second
only to towns well in our
draft joint local plan the town of neder
market
only has 186 homes for 25 years to
deliver
that there's more on this site that's
outside of the divine settlement
boundary of thurston than in the whole
of needham market
it seems to me like that the villagers
are going to seek to deliver
far more than the towns and that's
unsustainable
uh so what we're then asked to do is
actually look at adverse impacts
of approving something and personally
i think the biggest adverse impact of
approving this
will be the decimation of the
neighborhood plan here
and the confidence and commitment of all
those that worked in it
will have then been uh watered down and
you'll have less neighborhood plans
coming
and people think why should they bother
if a neighborhood plan can just be so
easily brushed aside
so i i for me the neighborhood plan is
very sacrosanct in this
uh and what and we're asking them where
they're going to deliver this other 400
why are we criticizing a community for
delivering a document that the
government has approved
and that we have approved i i really
don't understand
i think the highways are still a major
concern because it's based on
data that has a presumption
that's not from here it includes a
presumption
from the whole of the country when in
fact we know that vehicle use in suffolk
has actually had a trend of going
upwards uh when aggregate against the
whole of the country
that's very misleading and if that is
wrong
we're in trouble before we even start um
the health infrastructure uh the case
case officer said well
we as ward members where we're concerned
about health should be having
meetings with the ccg yes i've already
done that uh
and for the uh the baxter residents that
use wool pit
uh and their health center is closed we
were told guess what
go and put a put an application into the
sill pot
i can i can tell you if one of these
health facilities puts in
a a bid into the silpot the silpot's
gone it's not an elastic pot it's not
bottomless uh you can only spend this
money the once
so frankly i think this application
as pretty as it looks is an ideal one
for review
and it's certainly one i couldn't
support here today because of the
decimation
of a made neighborhood plan thank you
chair
thanks very much uh council ball boys
well thank you chairman um
yeah i think i think there are some
issues here
uh there's obviously been a great deal
of effort as we have demonstrated a lot
of joined up thinking
uh between um
different um authorities um and thank
you for the shout out about fishwick
corner
which shows you know coordinated work
between west suffolk district council
and and law developments uh
to improve uh traffic management um
it is i find it quite difficult i think
i do appreciate the background to this
there is enormous pressure
on mitsuba district council to
bring forward housing
this pressure is from central government
they calculated that they
calculate our housing needs with their
uh specific algorithm which
according to government papers they're
wanting to change which will
uh are going to rob baker which will
more or less
double the amount of housing mitsuba
district
council are going to have to bring
forward uh but that's a date
a debate perhaps to have outside
this meeting i think that the work that
has been done on the infrastructure
does address quite a lot of the
challenges that are within
than they that are identified within the
the neighborhood plan
um
uh shortage of certain types of houses
there's going to be
73 affordable houses
different kind
[Music]
their developments are the various road
junctions
are going to be improved um
i think some of the as council stringer
says i think this is quite a pretty
proposal i think it does
um provide a sort of increase in bio
device
by diversity there's so 20 meter buffers
along the sides of it there is joined up
thinking with regards to the cycle
past in in terms of its sustainability
um i i think it is
a worry that some outside providers like
the um
healthcare providers and in particular
network rail
the station at the station how they are
lagging behind
and the you know those um
infrastructure improvements that are
needed now adds
or at least to be sort of underway
um
the as council richard says that the
accumulative effects
of this development on thursday are
enormous
um council turner had mentioned the
an enormous increase in the amount of
journeys
um whether officer harvey could sort of
clarify that
i think six thousand per day
is is a frightening number um but there
are
is without doubt a substantial increase
in traffic already
and there will be further increase in
traffic
um there is a a tension between the
neighborhood plan
and the emerging local
plant and where the housing is going to
be
um
i think the identified challenges within
the neighborhood plan
have been addressed i'm not
i think a really good effort has been
made to
to meet them i am i've got
some doubts as to whether it is just
enough
or whether there is ins or whether there
is going to be any spare capacity for
any future
development um even though that could be
greeted with sort of um
a somewhat negative response from
thursday
um so i think that a lot of
good work has been done i think it is
vastly improved the
application um
[Music]
and it does demonstrate the fact that if
time is taken
over these applications that there is
time to sort of
produce more convincing arguments
in favor of it um i think i'm going to
have to stop that i still haven't quite
made my mind at whether to
approve it or not thank you thank you
councilwood boys
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to give a few comments myself i
would like to come in at the end
then i'll uh pass it on to philip isbell
and then after
uh philip's been then we'll open it up
for members to if you want to have
further discussions or you want to put
proposals
i'll leave that up to you but from where
i sit um
this has come a long way from where we
were
many months ago and for me
the road junctions were something that
lots of people have been unhappy about
and it's good to see that a large number
of work has taken place
to move forward as much as we can on on
the concerns that have been raised and
actually you know i think this shows the
benefit of things coming to committee
and where members aren't happy and what
we can actually achieve
um when we show our our concerns um
clearly to have uh i've never heard of
tiger crossings before um
but to have uh zebra plus or tigers that
they're called and you know that's
clearly a huge benefit
uh particularly uh with the comings and
goings obviously around the college
we've also seen now what i would really
describe
genuinely is significant environmental
upgrades and uh we had concerns about
the buffer the widths of the buffer
um and to see them come in and to have
listened and to come back with 20 meters
and you know i won't so so
it does really feel that the committee
has had concerns
a lot of those have been addressed now
council warboy summed it up
very eloquently and and it is the
ongoing
conflict that we all have at lots of
these meetings between the neighborhood
plan and the emerging local plan and
that's something that obviously each of
us will have to weigh up in our minds
uh uh we have we've had different
degrees of weight
um but i i do i do say that you know i
do congratulate actually
officers and the applicant for actually
having taken forward so many of the
points
and really having brought this forward
um
with such significant changes so you
know i think that shows
the work the committee uh has done well
so um before i open it up to other
members that's enough for me i'll i'll
hand over to
um philip isbell who wants to just come
in before we then can go through round
two or however anyone else wishes to
take it forward um in the next from
debate but uh philip over to you first
thank you thank you chairman yes just
wanted to pick up on a point because
there was a little discussion around
uh both the neighborhood plan and this
question of housing need
so um just to go back to what the
neighborhood plan actually says
uh as i did indicate um the neighborhood
plan
paragraph 4.2 it acknowledges it's for
the jlp to ultimately address the the
the oan the objectively assessed housing
need for the two districts so there's
you know there's a recognition locally
of that and the pla
the neighborhood plan then goes on to
say it's not expected that significant
additional growth will need to be
planned for in thirst and to support the
emerging jlp
i guess that speaks to you know
attention in
in the kind of strategy that that we
have here and
in terms of housing need i think you
have a paper that will be coming on
a government consultation to be coming
to full council uh imminently
about the potential change to the
housing methodology well
consultation is only a consultation it's
not a conclusion but i think we've heard
plenty from this government about
delivering on housing need and
the change to uh the the housing
methodology that is currently being
proposed uh would effectively uplift
uh the baseline for for mid suffolk
you know by by a considerable amount of
of
of new households so this question of
of housing and its uh and its
contribution accepting that you know we
may well have over
over a five year supply the question of
housing need is going to continue to be
important in
the question of how neighborhood plans
accommodate that and are realistic about
that
and i i would simply sort of reiterate
that when you see appeal decisions
wherever they are and perhaps the most
most relevant local one was
uh in i uh relatively uh
relatively recently you know the
delivery
of housing attracts substantial weight
you know and in this scheme we have a a
significant affordables content
uh and you know another element of of
the current
government consultation is to reduce
that out turn
for windfall sites and uh i believe
councillor
and colleagues in well committee members
in the meeting have discussed
the role of windfall sites they are
important in our district so we have an
opportunity to
capture both housing need uh and i think
the the fact that we may be in excessive
five-year supply would not
cut any mustard with um an inspector
were we to defend an appeal against a
refusal and
to that extent you have to weigh the
need aspect of
the relationship with the neighborhood
land very very carefully
eye's neighborhood plan was ambitious in
its delivery of
of of uh of housing against uh
need and the inspector drew an
on-balance conclusion i find that
quite telling um so i don't want
anything else jim because i think i've
said enough
i simply wanted to point out that the
recommendation exists both within the
recommended papers that you have in the
committee paper and in the table papers
because there are some additional items
on
page four and five of the tabled papers
which are in addition to the
recommendation in the report thank you
german
thank you vincent over to you
thank you i just wanted to um
add a little bit about the station
improvements that we've already secured
ahead of the
feasibility study because i think
councilor field you made a
a good point about how quickly can those
improvements come forward but i'd remind
members that the bait and road scheme
in providing the footpath widening under
the bridge
to 1.5 meters width
that is sufficient to safely accommodate
any additional rail usage from the
gladman
development we've been very careful with
our colleagues in suffolk county
highways to
analyze that and so gladman's
development itself will not um
add unduly to issues at the station so
what we're looking at is
in terms of the feasibility study is
enhancements for the whole village
just wanted to make that point clear
thank you chair
you can you just um just where i've got
you on the on on there just clarify
because
um the recommendation is on page 10a and
11a of the papers uh
through to 12a through to 13a and are
you saying with the addition of the late
papers that are on page four
to be added four and five to be added
just so we're 100 clear i
i am chair and the reason they were
added to that um
table paper was having listened again to
the meeting from the 29th of january
it was clear that when members moved to
a vote there were a number of items that
came up
that i thought would be equally
appropriate at this point in time so
we have included those were you minded
to ground planning commission yeah so so
what you're saying is the recommendation
for us is on page 10a
11a 12a and 13a of the papers that the
uh that were sent to us in addition we
want to add
the late papers to those as additional i
correct yeah correct just so i'm 100
clear thanks very much
okay uh next up is cancer matheson so
we'll go around again
thank you in light of what mr isabel was
was just saying um could he
could he say quite why we would need to
approve
this application at this time rather
than in 2025 or 2030
following what council stringer recently
described as an orderly review
of the neighborhood plan thank you
philip thank you chairman yes
um very simply um if we take all of the
plans which form the development plan
together
um and without boring you with this
you would have to identify uh adverse
impacts which significantly
and demonstrably outweigh the benefits
when assessed against the policies
are taken as a whole within the nppf you
do not have
up-to-date policies that uh uh
deal with the uh strategic and detailed
location of new housing growth
so the presumption in favor of
sustainable development will engage
whether or not you consider that you
have already granted a number of
decisions already
the presumption uh operates here and
will govern any decision made on it so
you have to take account of that
notwithstanding the
the ideal of a review process
i'm afraid that's a luxury which
the nppf uh does not afford you
okay thank you next up is councilman
muller
thank you chair uh chair i would like to
move approval of this uh application
based on the recommendations in the
papers that we currently have
thank you chair okay
uh you caught me slightly on the hot
there hold on
okay thank you uh counselor
guthrie you're next yeah well i was
going to move it but he's
jumped the gun on me well done um and i
will second it thank you um with the
additional
um items that uh were discussed a moment
ago thank you
okay uh we've still got plenty of time
for debate if
if people want it um cancer eben
um thank you very much chair i was just
um concerned that if we
um we're not concerned but if members
are looking to
i'm having heard from people looking to
um support this
um i just wanted to um get a little bit
of clarification on one of the
conditions
it's on page 11a and it's the
um one two three four five the sixth one
down
and it refers to um package of
delivery of the package of footway
cycleway pedestrian etc and it says
within an agreed timetable
um i just wondering if on the conditions
we could get some
more clarity um as to whether that
agreed timetable can be
say for example before the first house
is built
befo should be my ideal before the first
house is occupied or whatever
thank you chair well let's have clarity
um
first of all um from vincent then we can
go back to the
proposal and second i i think uh
the committee have made it clear in in
recent weeks something in particular
stow upland
that it would be appropriate for the
condition to say
the package of works particularly the
crossings
would have to be in place prior to first
occupation
i think that would give members the
comforter knowing that the safe routes
to school
and the ability to move around by foot
and cycle
with those three key junctions that we
illustrated would be in place
and i think that would also go some way
to satisfying
you council of war boys on the same
issue the question of the junction at
bunbury arms is more difficult
because that will be developed
installed by suffolk county council but
i see no reason why
the other package of works couldn't be
subject to a condition that says
installed prior to occupation
okay so that's on the delivery of
package of footwear psychoand
pedestrians prior to first occupation
are you happy with that
uh councillor mullen cancer guthrie yes
i'm happy with that chair thank you
thank you
okay thank you uh councillor field
you're next
i was just going to comment on the the
um the housing need
and the the numbers that uh reflected
through into the
thurston neighborhood plan
as i understood it from previous
meetings and previous discussions
perhaps
those numbers are not numbers the
government proposes
and then we may debate and decide
whether we're going to meet
or not they are essentially
a mandatory requirement you shall meet
those numbers
and if you don't meet those numbers
ultimately
your toys are taken away from you there
is a way of
overriding what you
alternative decisions so i think it's
fairly paramount that we meet those
and that we meet those on plans that
we've discussed
we've progressed we've obtained various
improvements to and that the decision
to my mind is is ours not that we take
the option
the easy option of bouncing it off onto
the inspectorate on every occasion
uh that to me shows a lack of
courage if you like it and our own
convictions
so i was just going to make that point
if i'm wrong please
let someone tell me i am wrong but i
believe
the numbers we must meet are essential
and that we don't have the option of
reviewing them in a few years time
thank you
vincent rafael do you want to come in on
that
uh sorry chairman yes um yeah in essence
the
um the methodology is uh is not
nationally imposed but there is a
proposal to to make it a national
methodology
but that said we are expected to meet
those uh targets as councillor field
says and we we do not have
the the luxury of not meeting those
targets so
uh yeah i i agree absolutely with the
sentiment that he describes there are
difficult decisions in the middle of
this and we can all
probably uh learn lessons around the
support and
extent of uh contribution we had to the
preparation of the neighborhood plan but
we are here
and we must work with what we have and i
would hope that from here on
there is there is a different approach
but meeting the need
is not this it's not a choice you can
turn away from
thank you council stringer you're next
thought to come back on what's been said
by uh our leader uh
planning uh it actually i've seen it
written more than
twice now uh from independent planning
advisors that
invoking a tilted balance upon the data
of
an up-to-date neighborhood plan is
actually an incorrect
uh appreciation of the policy situation
and
i don't know where we get this idea that
if a government
lobs a figure at a district
that it has to go into one parish i
i don't understand where we're getting
that logic from
yes we have to deliver the number but
our own
plans don't show that all of that number
should be
practically in one or two parishes
our draft joint local plan has not been
through that government inspection
the draft joint local plan where you're
deriving these numbers from and the and
where the proportions of those numbers
go
disproportionately affect villagers
without health facility in their own
parish against
towns three of your towns
parishes are delivering less than this
one village
so that has not yet been tested so what
you're then suggesting oh we'll just
keep adding more because
we've got to add more numbers because
government keep putting them on to us
we must deliver them yes we must deliver
them but actually
you need to deliver them across the
district
and your proportion of where you're
going to deliver them
has not yet been tested by that
government so
it doesn't show that we have the courage
of our convictions by approving
something
that our community and our ourselves
have agreed shouldn't be approved
that actually shows cowardice and we
should defend our neighborhood plans
because they are the most recent
document
anything you want to add philip to that
thank you chairman no i think i've i
think i've said enough about the
presumption
of thank you uh councillor medlin
thank you chair yeah um to me the
import of approving this site would be
to undermine the work
of neighbourhood plan groups across the
camp across the district
and uh if if any community was asking me
is it worth putting in the time and
effort to make a neighborhood plan
uh on the basis of root this and recent
decisions
you know from stockland to mendelssohn
and now to thurston i would
not recommend that they bother why is it
that we accept a plan
and then seek to overturn it or
undermine it or circumvent it at the
earliest opportunity
i do rate these plans and i will not be
voting in favor of this development
yeah i think uh that's the the the point
that's been made
uh so eloquently by councillor war boys
earlier isn't it it's the weighing up
of the of the neighborhood plan versus
the emerging local plan
anyway okay um i have no more hands up
so it has been proposed by councillor
muller and seconded by councillor
guthrie
as per the recommendation in our papers
on page
3a through to 11a
uh sorry through to 13a and additionally
on the late papers that were submitted
which is page
three through to page five
uh they are additional items with the
inclusion in the
uh in the uh uh recommendation
uh under the delivery of the package for
footwear cycleway pedestrian cycle
crossings to an agreed timetable
and and we're putting in there prior to
first
occupation so on that basis we will go
to a vote i'll now
ask uh claire to please do a roll call
thank you chair members if i could ask
you to say
four against or abstain when i call your
name
councillor james caston paul
councillor rachel ebern against
councillor john field
four councillor peter gould
four councillor kathy gough three
four councillor lavinia hadingham
four councillor matthew hicks four
councillor john matheson against
councillor andrew mellon against
councillor richard mayer
four yes councillor andrew mellon
oh you've done him i do apologize
councillor david muller
four council mike norris
poor councillor andrew stringer
against councillor roland warboys
four thank you i make that
ten votes four and four against if you
could confirm that please ian
uh yes and his legal advisor confirmed
ten votes for four against
thank you okay everyone well thank you
very much for joining us today
uh thank you to the officers uh for
preparing everything
uh and to claire uh and mandy for
getting everything together for us
online
um close the meeting at 12 37
and see you again soon no doubt thanks
everyone thank you matthew